The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RIK EBERHARDT: So welcome to
Creating Video Games, CMS 611
and 6073.
Is everyone in the right class?
Yeah, all right.
Cool.
So this class is taught by--
it's a Comparative Media
Studies course.
So we'll be talking a lot
about the kinds of things
that they talk about in
Comparative Media Studies.
We'll study research
and design practices,
but as it relates to
software engineering,
and in particular to
developing video games-- so
digital video games
for, basically, screens.
The CMS department has a lot of
different, really cool research
labs that are a part of it.
And we are one of them.
So we are the MIT Game Lab.
Basically the whole
MIT Game Lab staff
teaches this class together.
Because we really like each
other, and it's really fun.
But also because
there's a lot of you.
And it's a really big,
complicated class to teach.
So we need all the extra
support we can get.
We teach classes in game
design and game research.
Those are all the course
numbers that we teach other
than this one.
Maybe you've taken
one of these before.
Maybe you're thinking about
some other game courses
you want to take in the future.
So take a look at that.
We also have UROP opportunities.
So we'll advertise those
classes as they come up.
We do mentor Course 6
students for the UAPs.
What we usually ask
is for you to bring
to us an interesting
research topic that you
want to research.
And if we are also
interested, then cool.
A match is made.
Same thing when it
comes to masters.
So if you're going
to get your master's
of engineering here in Course 6.
And you want to do it in game
design or game development,
and you need a mentor,
we can be your mentor.
We also host a lot of
events and outreach events
and guest lectures.
A lot of the guest lectures
will be part of this course--
that we'll be opening
to the public,
as well, for a few of them.
We've got Riot coming
up in September.
We've got Japanese
developer Swery65.
Does anybody play
Deadly Premonition?
Yes!
It's awesome.
And he's coming
to talk about it.
And some other cool stuff--
we also do a lot of events.
So like game jams-- we'll
have an alumni panel.
And the next big thing is the
Boston Festival of Indie Games
is going to be on
campus in 11 days.
So 200 developers are
going to be showing off
their games over in the
Johnson Activity Center.
And we'll have a conference
track going on here.
So take a look at that.
You'll get all that information
as the course goes on.
So next up, we just wanted
to introduce ourselves
and our individual--
basically what we do,
and why we're
teaching the course.
PHILLIP TAN: Hi.
I'm Phillip Tan.
I've been teaching
various game courses here
at MIT for about 10 years now.
I'm a research scientist
over at the MIT Game Lab.
And I've worked with all of
these fine folk for many years.
Up here are a couple of
projects that I've worked on.
On the right is a game called
A Slower Speed of Light.
If any of you are interested
in relativistic speeds
and simulating
them on a computer,
you are welcome to check it out.
We also have an open
source version of our code
that lives on GitHub.
So you can download that
version using the same tools
that you might end up
using in this class.
But basically it's, you travel
near the speed of light,
and you see what
this might look like.
I play a lot of StarCraft.
Anybody here play StarCraft?
A few people.
All right.
I've been working with
Blizzard this past year
to work on their
spectator interface.
The idea is that there
are a lot of people
who watch e-sports right
now, especially on Twitch.tv.
Who watches Twitch.tv?
OK.
All right.
Lots of people.
E-sports specifically
on Twitch.tv, or just
like Let's Play?
OK.
A few.
Those are spectators, just as
if you're watching a football
or hockey game on TV.
And they need infographics
to come up in real time
when something interesting
is happening in the game.
So I write code
together with UROPs
to be able to bring up cool
infographics bring the hype,
basically.
So that's me.
SARA VERRILLI: Hi.
I'm Sara Verrilli.
I'm the development director
at the MIT Game Lab.
I came to the Game
Lab out of industry,
where I've worked as a
producer and a game designer
and originally, how I entered
it was as a QA tester.
So I've held a lot
of the jobs there.
I've worked with
a lot of students
on games when we were
still running the summer
program, the one we did with
Singapore-MIT GAMBIT Game Lab.
And now I have focused to mostly
seeming to work on classes
and teaching game design.
So that's a lot of what I've
been doing and what I've done.
RIK EBERHARDT: So I'm Rick.
I'm the studio manager
for the Game Lab.
I teach this course.
I co-teach with Sara 617,
our advanced game studio
course where you spend
the entire semester making
one game.
These are the games I've
worked on at the Game Lab.
I worked on all sorts
of different games
from anything to
games about depression
to games about identity, games
that are demonstrating advanced
3D rendering techniques, and
conference games-- PAX POX,
a game that was played live
action at PAX East in 2009
at our booth there.
So I do digital and
non-digital game design.
But for the most part
I'm studying and working
on project management.
ANDREW GRANT: Hi.
My name's Andrew Grant.
I'm the technical director
at the MIT Game Lab
and help out with
the classes too.
I'll probably be helping
you out a little bit
with technical issues
or what have you.
I was in the games industry.
I started with Sara
at Looking Glass
and moved to
Dreamworks Interactive.
And after that, I kind of
got burned out, to be honest.
It's a pretty rough
industry sometimes.
I spent about 10
years consulting.
And I kept coming back to
games and coming back to games.
And so when I got
the opportunity
to come to the Game
Lab, I said, well, yes.
So anyway, here I am.
I've been playing and
making games all my life.
And I think we'll have fun
doing it this semester.
RIK EBERHARDT: And if you can
stand up-- our TA is Paulina.
Wave and say hi.
She'll be helping with all
the administrative stuff.
She'll be helping
us with grading.
And she'll also be
helping with any questions
you might have about
some of the technology
that we're using, too.
She took the course
this past last year.
Great.
So get down your pencils.
This is the cheat sheet, the
one-line version of the class.
If you learn anything,
you learn this.
When you're working in this
class, the best way to succeed
is working face to face,
testing your games often,
prioritize, integrate, and
cutting features early.
Sleeping is awesome.
Avoid doing 3D.
Avoid doing network code.
And please use version control.
We're actually going
to require all of this.
But every year, a team or two
doesn't do one of these things.
And it's OK.
But they struggle.
So if you do all these
things, through the semester,
you'll do really, really well.
Yeah, please.
What was the question?
AUDIENCE: Slides.
Oh, the
RIK EBERHARDT: Slides?
Yeah.
All the slides will be
available on Stellar.
We're posting all of
our slides to Stellar.
I don't actually expect you to
take notes on all these things.
But it's awesome if you do.
I remember it that way.
PHILLIP TAN: This
is 140 characters.
RIK EBERHARDT: This was
actually Phillip's tweet
from last night, in case anybody
was following him already.
SARA VERRILLI: Then they
were probably not sleeping.
RICK EBERHARDT: Actually, yeah.
So the next bit
of administrivia,
we're going to go over
the syllabus a little bit.
It's in front of
you right there.
If you have any questions,
feel free to interrupt.
Fellow instructors, if
I say something wrong,
or if you want to say, hey,
but also this, please do.
So first thing-- the
course is structured
into four game projects.
So you're going to be making
four projects over the course
of the semester.
Our first three projects
are about two weeks each.
The third project is
a little bit longer,
if you decide to work
over the student holiday.
And then project four
is our final project,
our main project.
And that project's
going to be done
for a client who will be
coming in to talk about what
he works on later today.
So your first project is
a non-digital project.
It's a prototype.
Your second and third
are small, short,
digital prototypes-- so making
a digital game very quickly.
Your fourth is a longer
time period project.
But it should be about the
same amount of features,
the same amount of work,
the same amount of game play
as the first three.
It's just you had a lot more
time to actually do it right,
and to do it well, and to
polish on it, and iterate on it.
At the end of today,
we'll talk about what
we mean by these common themes.
This common theme--
what did I say--
meaningful decision making, or
meaningful decisions in games.
And each time we start a
project-- our first project
starts on Monday--
we'll introduce
the theme in more detail
and talk a little bit more
about it.
But you can see all of the
details about the projects
that we have available for
you at Stellar right now.
Our grading rubric
for each project
is largely team-focused.
So all of your projects
are worked on in teams.
They start in small teams
and get a bit larger.
You'll see each of these
lines is 20% of the grade.
So the actual working of the
game is only 20% of your grade.
Following the iterative
design process
that we'll be talking about,
using the project management
practices that we'll
be talking about,
doing a good presentation-- a
group post-mortem presentation
about your game--
is another 20%.
And then every
student will write
an individual post-mortem,
their own one to two page essay,
at the end of-- turned in at
the same time as every project.
And what we're asking for
all these things is we
want to know about your process.
We want to know how you made
the game, what challenges
you had while you were making
the game, what difficulties
you faced.
How did you surpass them?
And even better, what are you
going to do in the future?
When you either go
into the industry
or go into another
software engineering
project or another
class, what would you
do differently, after the
experience you just had?
So 80% of your grade
is team-delivered.
20% percent of your
grade is your own work.
So speaking of
in-class expectations,
the class is a three-hour class.
Holy crap.
And it runs twice a week.
Class time is actually allotted
for your work in teams.
We don't expect you to get your
games actually built entirely
within class.
But important team meetings,
test sessions, code
review-- you're
going to generally
have a lot of time in class
to do a lot of that stuff.
For projects one and
two, you'll probably
have about 60 minutes
at the most per session
to work on your team work
outside of an activity.
But we're also going to
have a lot of activities
where you're doing
some of the work that's
required in each project as
part of a guided activity
that we're going to run.
So it's actually a little
bit more than 60 minutes.
Products three and
four, we're probably
going to have about
90 minutes per session
for working in your teams.
And that's going to generally
be at the end of class.
At the beginning of class,
we're going to have, usually,
a guest lecture for
those last two projects.
And then we'll have
a playtest session.
And then it'll
just be open work.
Our original classroom
had flat tables.
This classroom-- that moved.
This classroom does not.
So it'll be interesting.
I don't know if it's got
power on any of the stations.
But the short version of it is,
bring your development station
to class, if you can.
If it's a laptop,
bring it to class.
You'll be using it a lot
starting Monday-- well
actually, starting
two Mondays from now.
And the other thing-- teamwork
is the heart of this course.
Actually, participation is
the heart of this course.
So even though we're
in this tiered thing,
and I hate giving lectures
to people this way,
we're going to ask you to
talk back to us a little bit.
So fill in the gaps
when you come in.
Participation is
actually very important.
Class participation-- so
showing up to class on time,
showing up to class at all,
and participating in class
is 25% of the grade.
So speaking of that,
attendance-- you
will be penalized if you
miss more than three classes
without justification.
So what is that justification?
It's like if you're sick.
If you're sick, we
don't want you here.
Stay home.
Don't make us sick.
Don't make your team sick.
He's a real stickler about that.
I'm invincible.
I won't get sick.
But everybody else will.
Do not be late.
Again, we're recording.
We have very important
guest lecturers
who are in our network
that we'd really
like them to enjoy being here.
So I really hate it
when people show up
in the middle of
a guest lecture.
It makes me feel like a jerk
for asking them to talk to MIT.
So don't show up late.
But do show up.
So if for whatever reason,
the doors are locked,
it really just means, hey,
there's a guest lecturer here.
And coming in is going
to disrupt things.
The doors will get unlocked.
I don't expect to
have to use that.
But if I will, I will.
Ha ha.
And usually, guest
lectures end about 2:10.
So you can come back.
Come into class later
to work, and actually
get counted for the
rest of the day.
So I'd rather you come
in later than at 1:15
while somebody's
talking up here.
Class is generally going to
start-- lectures are generally
going to start at 1:10.
We'll do announcements at 1:05,
if that makes a difference.
Because I know a lot
of people are coming in
from recitations and whatnot.
The other thing-- MIT has
an anti-harassment policy.
We've also got an
anti-harassment policy.
If anybody's on
Twitter these days,
or anybody's engaged in game
culture these days, it's toxic.
And it sucks.
And it makes me mad I don't
want to see it in this class,
please.
So this is on the syllabus.
It's the last page
of the syllabus.
Basically, don't make
offensive verbal comments
or any other kind of
comments about all
these different
things, when it comes
to gender identity, sexual
orientation, disability,
physical appearance, body
size, race, religion.
Just don't be a jerk.
Don't be an ass.
More importantly, though, if you
see it happening, let us know.
If you are a target
of this, let us know.
There's ways to get around this.
There's ways to report this.
In the syllabus, it
actually lists the website
for the official MIT
way to report it,
if you'd like to go that
way, if you'd rather not
come to either the
instructors or your TA.
And our email address--
videogames-bosses@mit.edu.
Email that.
Don't email us individually.
That makes sure that
one of us reads it.
SARA VERRILLI: Can I
add just one more thing?
RIK EBERHARDT: Yes, please.
SARA VERRILLI: Rick put
up a giant list of things
that you should
[? worry about ?],
and that you should
not be harassed about.
But I will go ahead and
say that you should not
be harassed about anything.
Right?
We have a list.
It's not meant to be exclusive.
So if there is for some
reason some other things
coming up and bothering
you, come and talk to us.
RIK EBERHARDT: We
are-- team development
and game development
is stressful.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: One phrase
that I've heard recently
that I love is, "Rights work up.
Rules work down."
You have a right
to be respected.
The rules that are listed
will be paper mached on
to make that work.
But in general, be respectful.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
That's really what
we're asking for.
Just be respectful
for each other.
You're going to be
working on large teams.
There are going to be deadlines.
It's going to hurt.
It's going to be painful.
Things are going to slip.
Don't let that be the
way that you express it.
We'll actually give
you some better tools
to express your
pain and suffering.
So the class is called
Creating Video Games.
How do we create video games?
We have a whole bunch
of people involved
in creating video games.
Was this the slide
you were coming in on?
Or is it the next one?
SARA VERRILLI: This is the slide
I was going to chime in on.
But you were chiming so nicely.
RIK EBERHARDT: Come
in whenever you like.
So basically, all
sorts of people
are required to make games.
We have all those
people in the room.
SARA VERRILLI: Actually,
a whole lot of skills
are required to make games.
You should not
come in and think,
I'm going to the
programmer on this team.
You should not
come in and think,
I'm going to be the game
designer on this team.
Or I'm going to be the
artist on this team,
or the sound designer
on this team.
The teams are small
enough, even when
you hit the eight-person
team for the large project.
And the projects are
always challenging enough.
Even if you think you have a
short list of things to do,
you have a challenging project.
That's one thing we've
noticed every single year.
Everybody manages to come up
with a challenging project.
The team's going to need you
doing everything you can do.
And that means that
if you can program,
they probably want
you to program.
If they need
programmers, chime up.
If you're primarily
a programmer,
or you think yourself
of, they need
you to chime up
on the game design
and comment on places
where it will work better.
And you understand
how it will work
better, because of your
understanding of the code.
If you're the game
designer, you've
got to be ready to pitch in and
help make all those things you
see in your head
happen, whether that's
creating some sketched
doodled art, so your team can
go with the little pixel
figures, or whatever.
We don't-- usually these teams
aren't big enough to support
someone who does
nothing but draw art.
We're not actually grading you
on the beauty of your games.
I mean, yes, we want good,
well-functioning, rounded
games.
We want games that are
relatively easy to use.
But you don't need super
beautiful art for that.
So if what you'd like to do
is primarily art for the game,
think about what else you can
be contributing to the game
as well, so that your game
gets more functionality in it.
And let's see.
For community managers, business
analysts, and marketers--
the people who are pitching
your game and talking about it--
don't mean on the
person who ends up
stepping up to organize
your team and steps
into the producer role.
They're already doing an awful
lot of job just producing.
They're going to need your
help figuring out presentations
and talking about your game,
and doing the reflection,
and keeping the team running.
So don't think of these as a
whole bunch of individuals.
Think of it as a whole bunch
of skills, one of which
may be your primary.
But choose at least two
or three as your backup.
That's my shtick.
RIK EBERHARDT: Cool.
And that's basically how
indie game development is run.
When you see a game
made by three people,
they're doing all of that.
And so that's basically what
we're expecting from y'all.
So if we're not teaching
a lot of the skills,
the main skills that we
are teaching in this class
is giving you
hands-on experience
working on complex
projects with large teams.
So what does that mean?
It's basically project
management, team management,
and communication skills.
You're coming to us through your
prerequisites with some design
skills.
You're coming to us with
some programming skills.
You have support for
some of the game engines
you haven't seen before.
But like any other
engineering course at MIT,
you pick up a tool.
You learn how to use
the tool in the course,
if you need to use it.
So the tools that
we've chosen should
be short enough that you
can be able to pick them up
pretty quickly.
And actually, we're going to
go into that today as well.
But the remainder
of the course--
particularly project
two and project three--
are going to be focused
on communication.
If you're on a large team,
how do you talk to each other?
How do you communicate
with each other?
Is it going to be through
email, instant message, chat,
post-it notes, mash notes,
hate notes, karaoke?
Bottlenecks are going to
form in your work process.
You're going to find out
that oh, all the assets are
going to one person.
And they're sick today.
The quality of your
code and assets
are going to quickly nosedive
if you don't have a plan.
SARA VERRILLI: Yeah.
This is another
one of those, don't
assume that one person on
your team is going to do
all the art or all the sound.
And that's all
they're going to do.
Because if they get
hit by the flu truck--
as frequently
happens around here--
you'll discover
you've got nothing
to put in the beautiful
game that you've made.
RIK EBERHARDT: So to
get around that, we're
going to introduce to you tools
and methods through the course
that are going to help you
get through these problems.
How to do code workflow,
how to do asset workflow--
we'll talk about
that a little bit.
That's actually the
first assignment.
We'll talk about code review.
We're not necessarily
teaching a lot of this.
We'll be talking
about a lot of this.
I know some of
you have done some
of this in other experiences.
We actually want you to help
other people out in the course.
Talk about your
previous experiences
working on a project.
If you've done an
internship before,
if you've made an
app for a company
before-- because everybody
has apps these days--
you've probably run
into some of this.
So we want to hear about
your experiences, too.
We're going to talk a lot
about product backlogs and task
lists-- paper!-- using paper and
spreadsheets to tell each other
what you've been working on and
how you're going to work on it.
I'll be talking a lot
about retrospectives--
about how, at the
end of a project,
you can talk about
what you've just done,
and how you can do it quickly.
But ultimately, we
can going to give you
all the tools, all the methods.
The best way to learn all
this, to know all this,
is really just through
prior experience.
So this class is going to be
that prior experience for you
when you go to your
next challenge,
either working in
the industry, working
doing any kind of
software engineering,
or going to another class.
So again, the cheat
sheet-- work face to face.
Test often.
Prioritize, integrate,
and cut features early.
Sleep.
Avoid 3D.
Don't do networking.
And use version control, please.
SARA VERRILLI: And
this is where the cut
I have from the last three
years of this course,
and the final presentations
from pretty much
every group that's given
a final presentation
for their final
project-- in which they
look at us sheepishly and say,
you said we should test early.
And you know what?
We really should
have tested earlier.
I can't actually be 15
different MIT students
who have taken this course
saying this sheepishly up
on the screen.
But I've heard it from
all of them, pretty much
every single group.
So I'm going to give you
guys the really early
heads-up warning.
Test earlier.
We say it.
We mean it.
RIK EBERHARDT: I'd like
to introduce Pablo Suarez.
He and his group will be
our client for project four.
So we're asking him to
give an introduction
of the kind of
work that he does,
and give a feeling for
what the kind of work
we're going to do in class.
The first three
projects are going
to build slowly towards that
final project in the theme
and strength of those games.
And in that fourth
project, he and his group
will come back in
again and tell us
more detail about what
they're really looking for,
and what kind of games they're
really looking at from us.
So take it away.
PABLO SUAREZ: Thank you.
Thanks Rick.
Thanks Game Lab team.
I'm very grateful for this.
And you-- I am grateful
to you, even though you
don't have much of a
choice that I show up
and you have to
suffer through me.
My name is Pablo, Pablo Suarez.
My strange accent
comes from Argentina.
I live in the Boston area,
where a fraction of my time
I'm a researcher.
I used to be a researcher
affiliated with MIT.
I just came from
the Lincoln Labs,
where I'm collaborating with
MIT folks there as well.
But most of my time, I work with
a humanitarian team-- the Red
Cross/Red Crescent
Climate Centre.
It's like a think tank within
the humanitarian sector.
It's based in the Netherlands.
We cover the planet--
187 countries.
I am in charge of research,
in charge of innovation,
mostly in charge of Africa.
And unfortunately for the world,
we have way, way too much work.
The workload is so
ridiculously huge
that in my opinion,
especially coming from science
and technology, we need
to change the way we
think about humanitarian work.
And if it is about
changing how we think,
traditional ways are
not working too well.
And that's why I'm here.
I love this slide.
We have a comfort zone,
which is doing things the way
we've been doing them.
Someone's hungry?
Go get food.
Someone's homeless?
Go give shelter.
Someone's sick?
Help them heal.
But we no longer have the
money, the brain power,
the equipment to deal
with all that's happening.
Too much is happening.
The climate is changing.
Environmental
degradation, urbanization,
political instability, weird
diseases-- you name it.
How can we learn more
about what we can do?
We need as humanitarian
workers to get into a new place
where we can do more
with what we have.
And that place is
outside our comfort zone.
Now magic can happen.
But very often, we step
out of our comfort zone
and we fall into the abyss.
It's not easy to
find the right place.
This is a risky endeavor for me.
I'm here hoping
that you guys will
accomplish one of two things.
One is maybe you
come up with a game
concept that has a life
after the end of your course.
You get your credit.
You graduate.
And the Red Cross
or others can play
a game that helps
someone understand
something, helps
someone do something,
helps someone collect
data about something.
And we'll talk more about
what are those things
that we want when we
get to project four.
The other one is maybe we can
lure you-- even if one of you,
even if one of the
Game Lab team--
to consider humanitarian
work as part
of what you may be doing
in your future life,
either as your job,
or as your hobby.
It's great fun.
It's a great
intellectual challenge.
The head of my team, Martin
[? Van Ahls-- ?] he's
an astrophysicist by training.
OK?
So you don't have much
awareness of the extent
to which humanitarian workers
can come from unusual places.
And we hope that MIT stops
being an unusual place
for humanitarian stuff.
So let me illustrate the
kinds of challenges we get.
This is an actual fax that
actually arrived in May,
2008 to the office
of my colleague Yusef
[? ayd-Shaloush, ?] who at
the time was based in Dakar.
Let me see if this works.
OK.
For those of you who know Dakar,
it's near those green pixels.
That's where, at the time,
the regional office was
for West and Central Africa.
28 countries going
from Mauritania--
where there have
been a military coup,
and there was bloodshed in
the streets and Red Cross
volunteers needed to learn
first aid to prevent someone
bleeding to death--
all the way to Congo
Brazzaville in the southernmost
part of this area, where there
was flooding-- urban flooding.
And as Red Cross,
we don't fully know
how to operate in rapidly
changing urban contexts.
We're used to a planet where
poor, suffering people were
either in conflict
or in rural areas.
And Darfur-- people going to
Chad-- needing shelter, aid,
all sorts of things.
Yusef has to deal with
those three and everything
in between-- chronic food
insecurity, Burkina Faso,
you name it-- insufficient
training for his staff.
And he gets this fax.
Now I want you to think
you're a decision maker.
You're someone who has to make
decisions and gets this fax.
It was issued in May,
referring to the three coming
months-- June, July, August.
And it says if we define
an extreme precipitation
event-- extreme
rainfall-- as being
in the top 15% of the
historical record,
then this year-- there
was a lot of text.
I won't bother you with that.
This year, because of sea
surface temperature anomalies
and other things that maybe you
know if you're an MIT student,
but it's not what we're
used to-- this year,
because of that stuff, the
probability of extreme rains
is enhanced from 15%
to between 40% and 50%.
So this fax is in the office.
And Yusef looks at it.
And what does he do?
What do you think he does?
What do you think the
humanitarian sector
does when we get information?
First of all, to
understand it fully
you need to stop doing
everything else you're doing.
You have to not answer an email.
You have to not sign the check
for the fuel for the driver
for delivering the
something or other.
And once you start
thinking about it,
what do I do with the
place with the green pixel?
Do I send-- I don't
know, one tent?
A thousand tents?
Where do I send
them, and to do what?
What are the chances?
When will it happen?
So my job is to
help the Red Cross
family and the
humanitarian sector
at large to understand science
that can help us make smarter
decisions.
Now if you want to
represent, to model,
with an experience of forecast,
this is how it normally works.
There's information that
allegedly can support action.
That is communicated with an
audience in a passive mode,
like a fax or an email or
a TV or radio announcement.
And then you hope
that people will
get it and do the right thing.
Of course, I leave a question
mark, because-- not always?
Now when I talked to people
about climate science--
about changing
climate conditions;
sea levels rise, so
we need new locations
of shelters; about El Nino
and changing risks of drought
and food insecurity;
about rainfall upstream,
therefore flooding downstream--
I would be talking science.
And the people I was
talking to-- they
had something else to do.
They had to go save lives.
And they were forced into
a room just like you now.
And I was talking science.
And I could feel the extent
to which I was successfully
shrinking their brains.
This is a metaphor.
There are very talented
and smart people
in the humanitarian sector.
But my putting them
into a passive mode,
talking jargon to them, showing
maps and graphs and so on,
was really not
accomplishing much.
So I had to try something you.
Oh, by the way, I remember
hearing the snoring
while I was talking science.
So it was shocking.
Because they were wasting
their time listening to me
unsuccessfully try to
communicate information
that can help save lives.
So I started doing other things.
And we're going to
get a five minute
flavor of the kind of
things we're doing.
So let's play.
You're a team.
Split in half.
Each one of you choose, are
you on this half or this half?
You're a team.
You're a team-- four teams.
There will be one winning team.
The winning team
is the team that
has the most people standing
by the end of the game.
We'll have a few
practice rounds,
and then we'll play for real.
OK?
You are not who
you think you are.
You're not some MIT
student or something.
You are magically, in the magic
circle of this game, a Red
Cross disaster manager.
OK?
Good.
Someone is celebrating.
You're hired.
We have no money,
but you're hired.
So there are three kinds
of things you can do.
And everyone will be standing
when the game begins.
One is to go like this.
This means I hope
there's good rains.
I'm going to take advantage
of this opportunity
to do good things when
there's good rains.
Train people.
Change the tires of the vehicle.
Build a shelter.
Write a proposal for donors.
Write a report to the donor
that gave me money last year.
All those things, you can
do when it's a nice day.
Now maybe there's
too much rain coming.
Then you can invest
in preparedness
against too much rain.
You make this gesture
like an umbrella.
And it means you're
preparing against the risk
of too much rain.
This could be
prepositioning relief items,
like tents, for those who have
to be displaced with the flood.
But it's better to do
it before the flood.
Because if you
wait for the flood,
then the bridge has
been washed away.
And you have no way to take
tents to the other side.
The other option you have is
to do a bucket-- something
to hold water from the sky.
If there's a risk
of a drought, you
want to collect water
before the drought
so people can have
water to drink.
So each one of you
can do three things.
Good rains, you go like this.
Too much rain, you go like that.
Too little rain,
you go like this.
What determines rains?
The probability distribution
function of precipitation
based on the past record.
So you guys are affected
by this PDF, this die.
You guys are
affected by this one.
A six is what?
Too much rain-- it's a
good idea to be like this.
If you're not like
this, you sit down.
You got it wrong.
A one is what?
Too little rain-- it's a
good idea to be like that.
Otherwise, you got it wrong.
You sit down.
Everything in between is what?
Good rains.
You better go like this,
or you got it wrong.
Practice round--
everyone stand up.
Because the winner is going to
be-- well, let me show this.
Losing players
[? all ?] get it wrong.
You sit down.
You're basically-- not
fired, but people suffer
because of your bad decisions.
And the winning team is
the team that, at the end
of the few rounds-- I will
arbitrarily declare the end,
because in the real
world, there is no end.
We'll have three practice
rounds, and then for real.
Most people standing-- so if you
guys have two people standing
and you have 10 people standing
and they have less than 10,
you are the winners.
And the winning team
will win a publication.
I will explain how you'll
have to fight over it.
So let's go back
to-- actually, here.
So that you remember the
three things you can do.
Each one of you has
to make a decision.
Two, three, four, or five,
it's a good idea to do this.
Six-- good idea to do that.
One-- good idea to do that.
You can have a
collective conversation.
But each one of you has to
be making one of those three.
If you're making none of
those three, you sit down.
You're fired.
You have 30 seconds to
consult with your teams.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PABLO SUAREZ: The
rains are coming.
Make your decisions.
10, nine, eight, seven,
six, five, four, three.
When I say stop, you have
to be in the position.
Three, two, one, and-- be
in the position or you're
fired-- stop!
OK.
Here we see a lot of thumbs
up, two buckets, two umbrellas.
Roughly the same kind of
configuration-- all right.
Let's see what
happens to this half.
Camera, I wish you good luck.
This is for you guys.
It is a five.
So if you're like
that, stay standing.
Otherwise, sit down.
You didn't invest in the good
things you could have done.
For you guys, let's
see what happens.
And it is a four.
If you're like
that, stay standing.
Otherwise, sit down.
Moving on to your
two-- practice round.
What are you going to do?
Those who are sitting, stay
sitting, but can give advice.
OK?
Make your decisions.
Five, four, three,
two, one, and, stop.
Lots of thumbs up.
Are you with these guys?
All right.
So you're the only
umbrella on this side.
Let's see how it happens.
There we go.
There's
A four.
Thumbs up, stay standing.
Otherwise, sit down.
This team not
surprisingly is weak.
They started with few.
Over here, you
guys-- there we go.
A two.
So if you're like that
or like that, sit down.
Now, the last practice round.
You receive this fax.
That's all you know.
You got these fax.
AUDIENCE: Are we
using the same dice?
PABLO SUAREZ: I am answering
your question by saying,
all you got is this.
There's a deliberate
scarcity of information.
You have 30 seconds to
make your decisions.
AUDIENCE: Wait, where are we?
PABLO SUAREZ: You are in the
place with the green pixel.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PABLO SUAREZ: 10 seconds left.
Five, four, three,
two, one, and, stop!
OK.
So in this team,
there's only three left.
One third are investing
in too much rain.
Here we have about eight or so.
Half or more are
investing in this.
No one-- oh, only one
person is going for drought.
Over here-- all right.
I see over here we have three.
So about half, also,
investing in flood protection.
Over here we have more than
before, two out of six.
Well, of course, what this
says is that on a normal year
the chances of this is
15%, or about one in six.
One in six is 16%.
But this year, because
of unusual conditions,
it's a flip of the coin.
So for you guys, I'm
going to flip this one.
Of course, you cannot now
change your decision, right?
It's too late now.
You either sent the tents
or bought the cement
for the shelter.
So I'm going to throw
this up in the air.
If it falls like
this, no problem.
It's like a three.
If it falls like this, too
much rain-- 50% chance or so.
It's a good idea to
have the umbrella.
Otherwise you sit down.
If it falls like this,
meaning it stops moving
and it stays standing, it's
a good idea to have a bucket.
You guys will get
the yellow one.
Ready, set, and go.
AUDIENCE: Yes!
PABLO SUAREZ: Flood.
Someone's very happy.
We love it.
So if you're not like
this, you have to sit down.
Now notice this interesting
feature of reality.
If you take the right
action, an extreme event
is not a disaster.
He was prepared.
He's happy that a
disaster happened.
Because he was prepared.
Which is a good thing.
A disaster is only a disaster if
it leads to negative outcomes.
If someone tells you it's
going to be 110 degrees today,
and you have some
health condition,
you turn on the
air conditioning.
There's no disaster.
Unless there's no energy
for your air conditioner.
OK.
Let's see about you guys.
You also got a flood.
So if you're like
this, stay standing.
Otherwise, sit down.
If this were the end
of the real game,
we'd have three standing here.
No other team has three.
So you would be declared
the winning team.
Oh, you got four!
So my apologies.
You would be declared
the winning team.
Congratulations.
Now.
[APPLAUSE]
PABLO SUAREZ: Thank you.
Everyone sit down.
And now we're going
to see what you
would do for real
in this scenario
where we have climate change.
Have you heard of
climate change?
Things are changing.
This is based on the past
record of precipitation.
But the past no longer
explains the present.
Things are changing.
So I hereby introduce
you to climate change.
This one is going
to be for you guys.
I'm going to throw this up in
the air with some spin, just
like the dice.
Look at you.
I love this face.
This is a very
productive silence.
I'm going to throw
it up in the air.
if it falls like this,
it means normal rains.
No problem.
It's like a three-- a
good idea to go like that.
If it falls like
this, too much rain.
It's a good idea to
invest in your umbrella.
AUDIENCE: Oh I get it.
PABLO SUAREZ: If it falls like
that, what is it representing?
It's too little rain-- bucket--
good idea to go like this.
This is for you guys.
We're going to imagine we
play three consecutive years.
Can you hold this for me?
No spinning, please.
No throwing.
For the other half, we
have this other one,
which is also climate change.
But the climate doesn't change
in the same way in every place.
So I'm going to throw
this up in the air.
If it falls like this,
it means no problem.
Good idea to go for thumbs up.
If it falls like
this, too much rain.
this, too little rain.
Go for that.
As a team, you have two minutes
to come up with a decision--
or more likely, one minute.
Go.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PABLO SUAREZ: Less
than a minute.
30 seconds.
10 seconds.
Everybody stand up.
Make your decisions.
Five, four, three,
two, one, and, stop!
All right.
Compared to the first
round with the die,
there's much more
proportion of people
investing either in too much
rain or in too little rain.
Can you notice any
difference between this half
and that half?
Not really.
Very substantial, phenomenally
different climate change
projections coming
from science-- this
could be like the
IPCC report, right?
And yet, you don't know how to
interpret those differences.
Thank you for incarnating what
happens in the real world.
OK?
We just are very
confused to understand
that the risks are higher.
So I will not roll it.
Because I would rather
keep sharing with you some
of the things we were doing.
But I can share with
you that you already
have-- no, I want to know!
Let's play.
I want to see what the
climate will bring.
And that's exactly the point.
We are creating your
appetite for learning.
And that's what games can
help me and my colleagues do.
We have a bunch of
[? reckless ?] people,
and suddenly they want to know
the real climate projection
for their project site.
All right.
Everyone can sit down.
So we went through
this-- oops, sorry.
This is where I wanted to go.
So that's the fax
that Yusef received.
You played, and you had many
more people going like that--
which is the right thing to do.
Now it's 50-50.
It could have been
that it doesn't flood.
But if you understand
the risks, you
can say to the
face of your staff,
to the face of your donor, or
to the face of the communities
you're helping, look.
I had reasons to act that way.
Because it went from one
in six to one in two.
And games can help process that.
What games can do is to
help embed information
into a system where
decisions have consequences,
and shape of the
information that becomes
available for the next turn.
So you can have more or
less resources and so on.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was wondering.
If you have a 50-50
chances, right,
and let's say it turns out
you made the right choice
this year, why not invest
more into better measurement
[? increments? ?]
PABLO SUAREZ: Exactly!
Why not invest more
in better everything?
We can.
But we don't have the money.
Right?
So we're talking to
Lincoln Lab and donors
and so on to help us
improve our ability
to sense what is going on in
terms of hazards-- including
too much rain, too little rain,
and other things-- including
vulnerabilities--
it's not the same
for me to be exposed to
100 degrees of heat wave
versus to an elderly
person with asthma.
Right?
And it's the same
with capacities.
What do we have, in terms
of skills and knowledge,
in terms of equipment,
in terms of experience?
The disease chikungunya--
has anyone heard of it?
So what are you going to do
if an outbreak of chikungunya
comes out to MIT tomorrow?
Right?
Knowing can help.
Sensing can help you
make better decisions.
In short, in my experience,
only games can do this.
Only games can get a
bunch of people together,
and in a very short
time understand
the role of information in
the context of decisions
that will have
consequences-- including
lifesaving or
life-losing consequences.
This is an example--
I'm going to skip it,
so I can get to the end.
But basically,
games can also help
you collect data and compare
one scenario versus another,
and see which are the things,
the aspects of the real world,
where people are failing
to get something.
And so you can
target your efforts
in capacity-building
training, et cetera.
This is one of the things
I will talk to you about.
I will want you want to help
us design games or playful
activities that can help people
make their decisions based
on forecast, as
opposed to always doing
as if it were the normal die.
And then if there's a
flood, as the forecast said
was more likely, you
go, eh, I don't know.
I wasn't prepared.
Which is what happens
quite frequently.
There are many advantages.
One is that we get
better performance
in terms of outcomes--
fewer sick people.
Better efficiency-- so you
save more per unit money
or equipment or et cetera.
Flexibility-- people
can do more if they
understand the forecast.
If you know that
Katrina is about to hit
your village or
your city, there's
more you can do in anticipation,
as opposed to waiting.
And once it slams,
there's very few things
you can do at that point.
Because if you step out of
your door, you're in trouble.
Games can create the
appetite, through confusion.
With the cone, you
were like, huh?
We deliberately
create systems that
push people to the
tolerable edge of confusion.
So that they want to
figure out, to make
sense of what's going on.
And then participants
themselves-- individually
or in conversation with
peers, they go like, huh.
So if we do this
and this happens,
I'll be better off than
if I do this other thing.
The aha moment-- the
epiphany, the revelation--
is constructed by the players.
And that has much
more lasting effect
than if I give you the answer.
No one remembers the answer if
no one was asking the question.
Very few examples-- these
cones are the result
of a collaboration with the
World Bank Chief Economist
for Sustainable Development.
He was trying to explain
a confusing concept called
deep uncertainty.
[? Jana ?] over
there-- can you wave,
[? Jana? ?] She's my partner in
game design, and facilitation,
and life.
She had the brilliant idea of
taking-- our cone had surgery.
Sorry.
Our cat had surgery.
And she thought, how about
using the cone of shame--
you know, for the creature not
to lick its surgery-- she said,
how about using that for
depicting this uncertainty?
Now we had students tossing
each one of those cones
100 times to see the
probability solution,
with and without
spin, and augmenting
the gap between what
you think will happen
and what actually happens.
A few other cases-- this
is from Hanoi University
of Science and Technology.
These was with 350 students
playing a game on dengue.
It's like a rock
paper scissors, where
three players are mosquitoes.
And they can either bite, or
with your blood, lay eggs.
And the other
players are humans.
And they can either
protect from biting
or attack the breeding grounds.
This was designed by students
at game design students
at [? Parsons ?] and
professors collaborating
with the other students.
This one is a
publication from NASA.
It doesn't get more NASA
than a rocket launch.
But if you look here, it says,
Erin Coughlan-- former intern
and now staff in my team.
And the Red Cross/Red Crescent
Climate Centre project.
You go to page 47, and you
see [? Munu. ?] [? Munu ?] is
a volunteer of the
Zambia Red Cross,
from the village of Kazungula
in Western Zambia on the Zambezi
River.
I mean, there's not much
electricity or NASA-ness
in Kazungula.
But he was trained as a
facilitator for a game
where, with cards
and dice, there's
rain that happens over there.
So her cup gets some water.
And then from her cup,
she passes the water
to the person next to her,
representing the upstream going
downstream.
She can get more water or not.
And it keeps going
until maybe he
gets water to overflow his cup.
He's in trouble, unless he
takes some action ahead of time.
And the game we're
designing is not only
with cups and to mimic
the upstream/downstream.
But we're also making a digital
game where people actually
monitor river levels.
And they make predictions.
They make bets as to what the
river level will be in two days
or so.
And then the winner wins points.
But they can use points to
buy information from upstream.
And then with that data we're
developing a hydrological model
that can help us better know
what is going down the stream,
and are we going to
have more flood trouble?
As you can imagine, it's
awesome to have NASA report
on some little project in
Western Zambia, in part
because we know
that we can partner
these on-the-field
game-based data
collection with satellite image
for ground truthing and so on.
This one-- because we
are being recorded,
I will not disclose
the full story.
But in short, we play the
game that had the same story.
You play with a 6-sided die.
You know your probabilities.
It was being played with
the top-level climate
scientists in this planet.
And as you can see
on the left, there's
all sorts of calculations
with probability distributions
and the cost benefits and so on.
Then we change the
probabilities on them.
And then we gave them that.
Just like you were
saying, what is that?
What are you going to use?
We just gave them that
graph and the caption.
And some of them were
saying, but wait a second.
Why are you giving
me this information?
It's completely useless in
the context of my decision
situation.
And then we told them,
this is the information
that you yourselves produced
in the summary for policymakers
of climate science stuff.
And they became fully
aware of the need
for them to improve the way they
communicate climate science.
This-- you may
recognize that dude.
I think it's the last time I
wore a necktie-- at the White
House.
I was given five minutes.
I begged for seven.
Seven minutes given, preceded
by extensive PowerPoint
presentations or other
forms of uni-directional,
so I had an audience that had
brain wave activity declining.
And I said hello.
My name is Pablo.
And this is not a Frisbee.
It's a hurricane.
Everybody stand up.
And people were
somewhat confused.
Some were standing.
Others were distracted, and
they saw people standing,
so they stood.
And I said, OK.
I'm going to throw this
frisbee in some direction.
It's a hurricane.
If it hits you in the
chest, it's trouble.
You're suffering.
Now if you sit down, it will
fly above your head, no problem.
It's like evacuation.
But if you sit
down and evacuate,
and the hurricane goes
in some other direction,
someone may still
your refrigerator.
Right?
You're doing the wrong thing.
So where it will go will be
determined by these two dice.
So you either say standing
or sit down to avoid it.
And I throw the things.
And I look.
And I throw in this direction
and in this direction.
People were being hit.
There was huge confusion.
No one understood
what was going on.
And then someone got it.
Double one, I throw over here.
Double six, I throw over here.
Interpolate.
So someone figured it out.
They said, oh, a nine!
It will go in that direction.
Everybody sat down.
And I threw the frisbee.
And it flew elegantly
until it hit
the wall of the White House.
And then I said, well,
you know, climate science
can give us this.
Think Katrina.
Think all that we could do.
We're here to help.
Thank you.
And that game was memorable.
It opened doors.
And it created
awareness of the value
of linking climate
science with decisions
of the humanitarian sector,
of the government sector,
and beyond.
So game play beats
PowerPoint in a million ways.
For me, as someone who has
to help others take actions
that save lives, I'd
say first of all,
there's active learning.
When you were playing, and you
were confronted with that fax,
you were saying, what is that?
What does it mean?
And what should I do about it?
It's about action.
And there's plenty of peer
to peer-- no, but look!
If it's 50%-- and people
learn from each other.
There are plenty
of "aha" moments.
It's fun, but it's serious.
And the fact that
it's fun is important.
Neuroscientists, including
some in this building--
I think Satra works
here-- have evidence
that if you are
emotionally engaged,
your learning goes
deeper and lasts longer.
There is also the
ability to collect data.
I didn't go into it.
But that's one of the things
I'd be keen on using with you,
if you are able to make
a digital game that
can collect data and help us
understand, what do people
know?
What do people think?
What do people want?
And then we can use it as
an optimization platform.
How much should we do?
How many people should
stand up next time
we have that forecast?
It's like a Monte Carlo
simulation, right?
You do things many times.
And you figure out,
what are the things
that you call optimal, based
on objective or subjective
metrics?
That's the website for my
team-- climatecentre.org.
Note the British spelling.
This is at the core--
why we love games.
There's an
experiential learning.
That's from our conversation
with your colleagues
at the Lincoln Lab.
You want to do things,
reflect what would happen,
form abstract concepts--
maybe I should do this
or that-- test it, and do
it again in a better way.
And it's much safer to
do this in game play
than to do it in the real
world, where if you fail,
you can fail soundly.
These are some of the
partners we have worked with,
including UN system, academic
organizations, Rockefeller
Foundation, and many other
partners like Oxfam America
and so on.
It's been delightful.
We have severe shortage of human
capacity to make this happen.
We have Jana, who will likely
come as a resource person
to interact with you
when I'm traveling,
which will be a lot
over the coming months.
There may be other
colleagues who
live in New York, who may come.
We also have Willow.
Willow, would you like
to wave your hands?
Willow is very likely
to become a consultant
for my team going
to Nairobi to help
people use digital devices
to map risks at the community
level.
Maybe there's a way to
infuse it with games.
She already developed games
for Tanzanian communities.
So in short, I wish you all
the best-- learning a lot
from these guys, doing a
lot based on what you learn,
and your own motivations.
And whether you like
it or not, project four
will involve doing
something for us.
Thank you in advance for
accepting those rules.
And there shall be more.
Thank you very much.
Oh and by the way, I will
leave this with you guys.
It's our publication--
a shared endeavor
of my Red Cross team and Boston
University Pardee Center.
It's called, "Games
for a New Climate--
Experiencing the Complexity
of Future Risks."
I promise you it's fun to read.
And it's available
online for free as a pdf.
ANDREW GRANT: I'm going to
talk about game engines.
And before I do, if
you want to think
a little bit about one of the
things that Pablo was saying.
It's about, one of the
things that a game does
is it forces you to look at what
happened, and sort of say, huh?
You figure out why
did that happen.
And then you try to fix it.
And that's actually
one of the things
I think is very much
like programming.
If you're trying to write
code, and something goes wrong,
often that's what the
process of debugging is like.
You go, why did the
screen flip upside down?
That just makes no sense.
And then you have
the aha moment.
And you can go and fix it.
Turns out that making software
is a lot like playing a game.
So anyway, we're going to talk
about game engine selection.
Because one of your early
tasks will be to sort of
try out a game engine.
We're not going to be using a
game engine for the first game
project.
But we want you
to be ready for it
when it comes to project two.
Now the first
thing to realize is
that digital games are
basically a software project.
They share a lot
of things in common
with software in general.
You're going to have a UI that
your user has to interact with.
There's going to be something
going on in the background.
For a commercial
or business offer,
it might be a
database or something.
There's probably going to
be either a design you're
working from.
Or you're making it up.
Or maybe you've
got a customer who
cares about what's going on.
You've got features.
You've got bugs.
We've got task lists.
All of the same sort
of managementy things
that happen, happen on software
projects and game projects
the same way.
There's a little bit of
a difference, though.
Games are a little bit
harder in some ways,
and easier in others.
But we're going to
talk about the ways
that they're harder, because
that's more interesting.
The thing that happens with
most business software-- or even
something like Photoshop.
Have any of you used Photoshop?
Excellent.
Photoshop is one of
those software packages
that-- a lot of people like
to take classes in Photoshop
before they get started.
If you sat down to
Photoshop, you probably
didn't think to yourself,
wow, this is easy.
And if you did, wow.
But basically, Photoshop has
hundreds, or perhaps even
thousands, of features in
there that you don't know about
until you've taken the classes.
And if you want to
figure out something
about Photoshop, your best bet,
really, is to go to a search
prompt.
And go to your favorite search
engine to find out what to do.
Or ask someone who knows.
Because actually
trying to figure out
Photoshop from first principles
is really, really, really hard.
The thing is that with a
game, you can't do that.
You can't get away with that.
If your game is
complex, no one's
going to take a training class
to learn how to play your game.
Now it might be the
case that someone
will look at a walkthrough
or a cheat sheet or something
to play your game-- after
they've played for three hours
and decided they liked it.
But they're not going
to do that first.
That's a general, broad,
sweeping generalization.
There are some people
that like nothing
more than to read the
manual for a game.
They mostly died out
about 10 years ago.
But there are still
some hanging on.
Generally speaking, nowadays,
you're going to play the game,
and then you're going
to decide if you're
going to read the
instructions or not.
And this is going to be
true for your games as well.
So your UI task-- your
user interaction piece
for your game-- is
going to be hard.
And the only way to make
sure that works properly
is to test it over and over
again, as early as possible.
So that's one way
in which games are
going to be a little bit
harder than normal software.
Also, games have to be fun.
And we use the word
fun kind of loosely.
And we're always scared
of using the word fun.
Because there are serious games.
There are games that are
supposed to make you think
instead of get a big
smile on your face.
But what they have to be is
engaging, or interesting.
Photoshop's not a great example.
If you're playing with
Photoshop as an undergrad,
you're probably thinking to
yourself, this is kind of fun.
But if you're using a fancy
piece of software for work,
you're not doing that
because it's fun.
You're probably doing it because
someone's paying you to do it.
The games-- not so much.
People are going to play it
because they want to play it,
and for really no other reason.
So your game has to be fun.
And what you think is fun
they may not think is fun.
So the only way to make
sure that your game is fun
is to find some
users really quick,
and try out your game on them
as soon as you possibly can.
The same thing happens with
your game play difficulty.
By the time you're
done with your game,
you're going to think
the game was too easy.
I guarantee it.
And everyone who plays
it for the first time
will think it's too hard.
I guarantee that, too.
So you have to test it with
other users, not yourselves.
Because you will think
your game is too easy.
And you'll be wrong.
And then, of course,
finally, your game
may have an impact
you want to have.
And I'm going to keep
saying this over again.
You're going to have
to test your game.
Remember, there's a theme that's
going to keep going on here.
And we're going to use
this theme with absolutely
everything we do.
When you're playing a
game, you try something.
It doesn't work.
You think about it.
You try something new.
When you're developing a game,
you're going to try something.
It's not going to work.
You try something new.
When you're trying to make your
team work smoothly together,
you're going to try something.
And that's not going to work.
And you'll try something new.
We're going to talk about that
circle over and over and over
again in the class.
Because it works.
So moving on, we're going
to talk about game engines.
And if I talk to
quickly, as I have
a habit of doing-- even more
so when I'm talking to people--
let me know.
Tell me to slow down.
So this is the game
you want to make.
It's beautiful.
This is the tools
you have to make it.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW GRANT: So obviously,
what you're really going to do
is going to be somewhere in
between these two extremes.
And you have to think
really hard about how
you're going to accomplish it.
The vast majority of game
developers, especially
new ones, are going to
come into it thinking,
this is the awesome, perfect
thing I want to create.
And then they're going
to come to their tools.
And they're going to discover
that it's really hard to do.
And so I encourage you--
rather than thinking
of the big vision of
what you want to make,
and then figuring
out how to get there,
I recommend thinking
about what you've got.
And then figure out,
what can you make?
Now these are a couple
things you can do here.
One, reduce in
your mind the scope
of the thing you're
going to make.
You're not going to
make your favorite RPG.
You're not going to make an MMO.
If you try, we
will laugh at you.
You will occasionally
think about this top row.
How do I get the awesome thing?
But I really want to
encourage you instead
to think, as much
as you possibly can,
this is what I know how to do.
These are the tools I have.
What awesome thing can
I do with these tools?
Rather than, how do I get over
there when I'm way over here
right now?
This is a quote
from a discussion
I had with a game
team once where
we were talking about a
particular technical problem.
And I said, how hard is that?
And the developer
says, well, it's
really hard because of this,
that, and the other thing.
I said, wait.
Stop.
Actually I didn't mean that.
I don't care how hard it is.
What I want to know is, how
long is it going to take?
And we're going to say that
a lot in this class, too.
We're going to say,
how hard is something?
And often what we
really mean is,
how long is it going to take?
Because we don't
care if it takes
an hour of really hard
thinking, to some extent.
What we care is that
it takes an hour.
If it's going to
take you an hour
to do an easy thing-- like
sort a bunch of yellow stickers
and a bunch of orange
stickers because that's
part of your game prototype.
If it takes an hour to
do that, that's an hour.
It doesn't matter that
that's an easy task.
That's time.
And you have to
be careful how you
spend your time in this
class-- actually, through all
your classes at MIT, I suspect.
But in this class,
we know that you
don't have enough time
to get done every thing
that you want to get done.
And so you have to
think very carefully
about how you spend your time.
It turns out that game
development is already hard.
You don't need to
add hard stuff to it.
So a lot of what we're going to
focus on with choosing a game
engine and all the
decisions you make is you
want to write as little
code as possible.
And that's not because
we're afraid of code,
but because every line of
code you write is time.
Every 10 lines of code
you write is a bug.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW GRANT: Right?
So what we want to do
is minimize the number
of lines of code you write.
We want to minimize the
number of bugs you write.
Because when it gets
to be the bug stage,
that takes even more time--
to find it, to fix it,
to write new code to fix it.
So we want to reduce as much
as possible all of that time.
So we want to use
all the tools we
can to reduce the amount of
code we're going to write.
One of our big ones is we use
what we call paper prototyping.
We don't actually mean paper.
We mean whatever materials
you can use-- chalk,
pieces of plastic,
dice, frisbees.
Anything you can use to make
your game without writing
a line of code,
you should try it.
Test it that way.
Because it's so much
faster to test it that way.
When else do we have up here?
Iterative design-- I've
talked about this before.
We're going to use
the phrase iterative
design to talk about that whole
cycle where you try something,
see how it worked or didn't
work, change it, try it again.
That's iteration.
And we're going to talk about
that a huge, huge amount.
And one of the big parts
of this, of course,
is game engines.
Which is not to say
that you're going
to build your game engine.
But rather, you're
going to try stuff.
And the game engines will
let you iterate faster,
do more with less code,
and get more done.
All right.
So again, you're going
to use a game engine
to save yourself some time.
You don't want to
reinvent the wheel.
I'm confident that
you could write a game
engine if you wanted to.
But I don't think
it's worth your time.
Someone else has
already done it.
They may or may not have done
a better job than you can do.
But you can bet that
the thing that you're
going to get from
your game engine
will be faster than if
you stopped and wrote it
from scratch.
And then finally,
the game engine
that you write from scratch--
for every 10 lines of code,
you've got a bug.
I'm making that number up.
But it sounds good.
That means that a game
engine you write has bugs.
Now I'm not going to
claim that the game
engines that we're
going to suggest you use
don't have bugs.
They totally have bugs.
But what we have is 10,000
monkeys on the internet,
using that game engine,
reporting the bugs.
And there have been a lot of
cycles of people fixing bugs.
And so hopefully, the worst
ones are out of your way.
The other thing you can
do with a game engine
is you can use it
as you tinker toys,
as we talked about before.
Your game engine has a list
of things it does well.
Great.
Use those things as tools.
Take advantage of that.
Do everything you
can with those tools.
And if it can't do
something, don't fight it.
Don't say, game engine, darn
you, if only did this thing.
Think, how can we change
our design to not need that?
That's another
advantage you can use,
another trick you can play.
If you limit your
design, sometimes it
increases your creativity.
And it can actually help you
get your game done faster.
So throughout this
class, I use this phrase.
I'm not sure anyone else does.
But I consider certain
things to be nooses.
There are some things we
will tell you you cannot do,
or that we tell you
not to do, flat out.
And those things--
don't do them.
OK?
But there are some things
that we're going to say,
we recommend that
you don't do that.
Or, you know, no team has
tried that and succeeded yet.
Those I consider nooses.
You can try them.
And you can put
your head in there
and see how comfortable it is.
But probably by the
end of the class,
you'll say, wow, you know what?
When you said not to do
multiplayer networked play,
you were right.
We have heard that every year.
We will hear it this
year, I suspect.
But again, we're not telling
you to never try crazy things.
But merely be aware of
what the crazy things are.
If we're suggesting that you
not try something, but not
telling you you can't do it,
and we're looking kind of pained
when we say it, be
aware that this is
a huge risk for your project.
Be aware that this is a place
where you should be putting
a lot of early attention to make
sure that you have a back-up
plan if it fails.
All right.
On we go.
Now we're actually going to talk
a little bit about the thing
we're supposed to talk about.
Picking a game engine
is super important.
Everything involved in
your game relies on it.
But again, contradictorily,
don't worry about it.
Because you have four projects.
And the first one doesn't
count for game engines,
because you're not
using a game engine.
But for two and three,
I'd say experiment.
Try some stuff out.
By the time you
hit project four,
you should have some
opinions about what game
engine works well for you.
And try to get there.
Try to use the one you're
comfortable with by then.
But experiment on the first two.
No game engine's
going to be perfect.
They all have flaws.
They all have advantages.
And your job is to
find the game engine
whose advantages you like
and whose disadvantages you
can live with.
And that will be different
for different people.
All right.
Here we go.
So the most important
things we're
talking about for
game engines-- this
is not an issue for this class.
We're only recommending
free game engines.
But in general, if you're
trying to pick a game
engine or a software of
any kind to help you,
these are the three
categories of cost.
I call things free if you
don't care about the cost.
If it's $20, it's
practically free.
But if it's $1,000 and
you're a college student,
that's not free.
That's painful.
And if you're corporation,
however, $1,000 is free.
So these categories change.
For us, we're
talking about free.
Impossible is CryENGINE
or something brutal
where you get the source
license and do everything.
But we're not going to do that.
So this is the first one
that actually matters.
It's does your game
have requirements
that the game
engine has to meet?
And for most part, in this
class, this also won't be true.
Because you can choose your
requirements based on the game
engine you're choosing.
And our games are
pretty small scope.
But basically, if you
need a special input,
if you want to
publish to iOS, if you
need to support network play--
which you don't, remember--
then that might affect which
game engine you choose.
This one is actually my
biggest important thing.
Whatever you choose
for your game engine--
and we're actually going
to give you a short list.
So it's not quite
the open free-for-all
you might be worried about.
It should be easy to learn.
And there's a couple
reasons for that.
But the main reason is simply
the amount of time you've got.
We don't have a lot of time.
You don't want to spend time
mastering a game engine.
You want to spend time mastering
the art of creating games.
So you want to pick something
that's well-documented,
that's got a good
online community that's
going to help you out.
Even if you don't
ask the questions,
in a big enough
online community,
someone's already asked
the question you have.
I suspect you're all
familiar with this point.
We can do a search for the
question you have on something.
And some forum post pops up
where someone else has already
asked the question you have.
And you just read the
answers and think, yay!
There was an answer.
Or probably, there
wasn't an answer.
I'll look at a
couple more of those.
And so you can get an
idea for your game engine
as to how robust the community
is, how good the support is,
by sort of looking and
seeing how much support there
is online for it.
One thing on in-house experts--
it's very common for a team
to come together and
say, well, we all
know this game
engine a little bit.
But there's this one
person on our team
who's just an expert
in this other one.
So we're going to rely on
that person to really teach us
how to do it.
That only, only works if
that person is really willing
to be a teacher.
And it's not a bad
thing if they're not.
But don't choose their engine
based on their expertise
if they're not willing
to really be a teacher.
And what I mean by that
is that that person will
have to be willing to not
write code a lot of the time.
Because their time is better
spent teaching everyone else
how to write code.
And that really means
that if you find yourself
in that situation,
where you think
that you are the expert
in a particular engine,
and you're trying to
get your team to use it,
really think about yourself and
how you're feeling about that.
Make sure that you are willing
to not dive in and write
the code.
Make sure that you're
willing to help everyone else
do it instead.
Because that is going to
leverage more of your team.
On a small enough
team, that's not true.
So on your two- or
three-person team,
you can probably get
away with that expert.
On an eight-person
team where five of you
are coding something, you really
can't lean on that one person
that heavily.
You're going to
need to spread out
the knowledge as best you can.
And so some game engines are
easier to learn than others.
It's not just a matter
of the online support.
But we'll get to
that in a little bit.
On a team programming
project-- and this
is a personal bias of mine.
And I admit that
some people disagree.
But I personally think that
a strongly typed programming
language is a must.
If you're talking about
five to eight programmers,
there's an additional problem.
Whenever I write a
function, and you're
going to call my
function, you have
to know what the arguments are
to know what's going to happen.
And a strongly typed language
will enforce that contract.
It will make sure that we're
on the same page, at least
a little bit, as to what
that function is doing.
A lot of you are probably
used to-- MIT teaches,
in a lot of the
programming classes,
it uses Python, which is
awesome for quick work.
And it's awesome for a
single person doing work.
But it does kind of
start to fall apart
on a larger team, when you have
to read someone else's code
to know what their
function is doing,
what the arguments
are supposed to be.
If instead, you have a strongly
typed from the beginning,
the compiler will enforce
this communication.
And we're going to talk a lot
about teams and communication.
It turns out your code is one of
your methods of communication.
The actual written
text in your code
is a way you talk to
your team members.
And a strongly
typed language sort
of forces you to keep that
communication line clearer
than a weakly typed
language will.
And again, this is one
of those things where
programmers might have battles
over whether or not it's true.
But I'm pretty
confident of this one.
I would say it's a noose to
use a weakly typed language.
A lot of our game engines are
going to be talking about C#,
or ActionScript or whatever.
And I'm going to tell you
that if you know one of those
languages-- if you already
know Java, for example--
it's really easy to
transition to C#.
It's pretty easy to
transition to ActionScript.
ActionScript and Haxe
are very similar.
So I would say any
of those top four,
you can transfer back
and fourth pretty easily.
JavaScript, kind of.
But don't try to transition
to C++ from those quickly.
I mean obviously, you should
someday learn C++ if you are
considering yourself a
Course 6 major or whatever.
But don't assume you could pick
up C++ in a weekend because you
already know Java.
They're just gotchas in C++ that
don't exist in those languages.
And other important
note, if you know Java--
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW GRANT: It really looks
like you know JavaScript.
And you kinda do.
But you don't.
And that's not to say that you
shouldn't make that transition.
But be aware that it's going
to take a little bit longer
than you think.
There's a lot of
synthetic sharing.
But JavaScript is a
weakly typed language
that has a lot of weird,
very web-specific features.
And just be aware that that's
not as easy a transition.
I talked about ease of
understanding and learning.
Actually using the engine
is also very important.
How are you going to
get stuff done in it?
If the engine has an interactive
debugger, that is wonderful.
If it doesn't, then
you're relying mostly
on print statements.
And that's hard.
If you've never really had the
joy of using a debugger before,
I recommend you try to learn.
Because it's really an
extremely powerful tool.
We're not going to get into
that in detail right now.
And source-control-friendly
is another important one.
If you're on a team
with eight people,
you're all going to
be making changes.
We're going to talk more about
source control in the future.
We're not going to go
into details on that now.
But basically, it's
a way for your team
the team to communicate
and make sure you're always
in the same, up-to-date
source code for your project.
And if your engine
doesn't support that,
then you can be in trouble.
In the past, for
example, people have
talked about some of the cool,
sort of hobbyist game engines,
like GameMaker, or back in
the day, just bare Flash.
And those are really cool tools.
But they would save
the entire project
as one monolithic binary file.
And so if one person
makes a change,
no one else can change the
code while they're doing that.
Because there's no way
to merge our changes.
Whereas with code or text
files, or a good game engine
that separates things
out a little bit,
one person can
change an art asset
while someone changes a code
file, while someone else
changes yet another code file.
And it all merges together
pretty seamlessly.
And that's what you're
looking for, if possible,
on a team project.
I talked about this
before, but you really
want a product that's
been around a little bit.
It's cool as a hobbyist
thing or a solo product
to take on something
really brand new.
But I think for a
class where you're
trying to get stuff done
really, really fast,
and you're working
with a team, you really
don't want to go too far in the
direction of the new, latest,
and greatest thing.
Because you want to
have a game engine
that people have
put some miles on.
They've tested it and
shaken out some of the bugs
before you get to it.
All right.
Those are things
that I consider--
you've got to have
them for a game engine.
Here's some stuff
that's kind of nice.
Yeah, it's nice to be able
to easily import images
and sounds and stuff like that.
It's nice to be able to get
the source code to the engine.
But it's not essential if
the engine's well documented.
Let's see.
It's nice if you have an
integrated development
environment that can help
you with auto-completion
of various functions and
really help you along
with your development.
Definitely nice,
but not necessary.
And then finally, an
editor of some kind--
if I want to lay out
my levels in some way,
is there a graphical
editor for me to do that?
That's certainly nice.
And a profiler that would tell
me where my game is slow--
that's also nice.
But without these things,
you could probably get by.
Bells and whistles--
this is actually
relatively unimportant,
especially for a small project,
prototype-style stuff that
we're going to be talking about.
For the most part,
you don't need
all the fancy stuff like
particle systems and shaders
and physics and all that stuff.
You might use physics
in this class.
But be careful.
So that's one of the things.
You don't need that
stuff in your game engine
for most small games, at least
in the scope of this class.
These are things
that I really don't
care about-- scripting languages
that your designer might use.
Why is your designer not writing
code in your strongly typed
language?
I never understood that one.
Some designers are
afraid of writing code.
But hopefully in
this class, you're
at least willing to
try writing some code.
And then finally, just
because someone has made
a beautiful game
in a game engine,
that has no bearing
on whether or not
your game will be beautiful
in that game engine.
The vast majority of the time,
a game built in a game engine
is beautiful because they
have a really good art team.
And we don't have a
really good art team here.
We don't have the
time to do that.
And we don't have the
resources to do it.
So you shouldn't
measure your game up
against the beautiful AAA games.
You should be
measuring your games
up against some indie, quick,
prototype type of games.
All right, so
Flixel is the thing
we've been recommending
for many, many years.
This is the game engine that
is easiest, has the quickest
learning curve I've seen.
It gets everything done.
It's very quick
to learn, to use.
And it runs on the web.
Great.
That's pretty good easy stuff.
It was developed by Adam Atomic
for a game called Canabalt,
that you can see up there.
The game that, as far
as I know, sort of
popularized the infinite
runner genre, which we've seen
clone after clone
after clone of.
But I believe this
is at least where
it entered my consciousness.
And therefore, it must be where
it came into the world, right?
But anyway.
The cool thing about it is
it's got a very, very, very
simple object-oriented
state-based system.
It's really, really good
for 2D sprite stuff.
Last year, we had a bunch of
game engines for people to try.
By the end, pretty much
everyone just used Flixel.
Because it was easier to use.
And this kind of
says it all to me.
Even if you haven't
used ActionScript,
the learning curve
on Flixel is awesome.
You'll spend a day
or two staring at it.
And then you'll know most of
everything there is to know.
And you'll just be
able to do stuff.
You won't be able
to do all the cool,
awesome stuff other game
engines will let you do.
But you'll be able to do
pretty much everything you'll
need to do on the scale
and scope of games you're
looking at in this class.
Let's see.
It doesn't so good at GUI.
If you wanted a fancy GUI--
lists and lots of text
and buttons and
sliders and stuff--
it's kind of a pain
to code that up.
Right.
So Flixel is also unfortunately,
in its current form, kind
of in an end of life cycle.
And I've been saying that
for two or three years now.
And it's still holding on.
Because Flash is
still holding on.
Adobe is trying
to sort of get out
of the business of maintaining
Flash as a web development
place.
And I'm not really sure why.
Apparently, Adobe
decided a while back
that HTML5 was the future.
But it's been four
or five years now,
and HTML5 is still
not the future.
In the meantime, we're
sort of hanging on
with Flash and the occasional
JavaScript HTML5 thing.
I suspect it was actually
more of a financial thing
than any actual HTML5
preference thing.
But anyway, we're trying
to get out of Flixel
a little bit in the long term,
because Flash is going to be
a dying platform pretty soon.
PHILLIP TAN: Can I just
add something to that?
ANDREW GRANT: Please.
Stand near me.
Because I have a microphone.
PHILLIP TAN: All right.
I'll stand right next to him.
So the mic can pick up.
One thing to keep in mind-- that
are free versions of the Adobe
compiler for Flash, called
Flex, that you can download
for Linux, Mac, and PC.
However, there is also
this licensed version,
which you can download
for a 30-day trial,
called Flash Builder.
Unfortunately for Mac
users in particular,
if you want to get
those, I use it.
I like writing code in it.
But as soon as that
30-day free trial is over,
you are on an annual
subscription paying Adobe money
every year.
So "free" with an asterisk.
If you want to do free
development on a Mac
and use Flixel, be
very, very careful.
And use this upcoming
exercise to actually ensure
that the things that
you're downloading
and the things that
you're signing up for
are actually free, and not
free for the first 30 days.
For PC users, you have
the advantage of using
FlashDevelop, I believe.
That's what it's called.
That is actually a
tool that you get
without having to pay for it.
For Linux, you are
pretty much stuck
to using command-line compilers.
And if you really want to do
free development on a Mac,
you're also using
command-line But there's
all kinds of clever things that
you can do with text editors
to sort of make that a
little bit more comfortable.
But just keep that in mind.
That's another reason
why Flixel isn't
our number one choice, nowadays,
is because Adobe's really
trying to squeeze money out of
everybody, including students.
Adobe's insane.
ANDREW GRANT: One
can't blame them
for trying to make a
little bit of money.
However, it's no longer as
attractive as it used to be.
That's certainly true.
Unity is the next
one on our list
that we've had
good success with.
It's a free,
full-featured game engine.
It's got all the bells and
whistles you could want.
It's a little bit
dangerous to use it,
because it has all the bells
and whistles you could want.
And you should probably
only use some bells, and not
the whistles, and whatever.
You should be very
careful and judicious
in your use of the features.
Because the tinker
toy model of, only
do what the engine lets you
do is a little bit dangerous.
Because it lets you do
pretty much everything.
So you have to be very
careful about which
features you choose to use.
However, it's great.
It's free.
It does a whole
bunch of neat stuff.
There are paid versions.
But you won't need them
for the class, certainly.
I call these disads.
3D is harder than 2D.
And 3D is at least three
times as hard as 2D, really.
It's rough.
If you've never
done 3D before, it
takes a while to get
your head into it.
Even if you're doing
a 2D game in Unity,
sometimes you have to think in
3D a little bit, which makes
it a little bit harder to use.
On the other hand, Unity
does have this nice editor.
And it's possible
for a non-programmer
to get some stuff done
in Unity in a way that's
not possible in others.
You spend more time
learning the GUI.
But you can actually get
some more things done.
So it's an interesting
little trade-off there.
It is also, again,
not good at GUI work.
They're starting to
address that a little bit.
But it's hard.
You have to kind of hand code
your buttons a little bit
sometimes.
That is improving, as I say.
But it's not quite there yet.
It suffers a little bit
from the problem of merging.
Unity uses particular
objects that you really
wish you could merge-- just so
they're text files or code--
but you have a whole scene
of objects, for example.
And only one person can
really work with it at a time,
unless you're
really very careful.
So when you're using
Unity, you have
to be extra careful
with your team
to make sure that
people aren't messing
with the same files
at the same time.
The code, however, works
the way you want it to.
And source control works fine.
So you've got to be careful.
But you can work around it.
Moving on to the ones that--
you know, we want some of you
to practice with these.
But-- oops, that's
the wrong one.
I left a slide in
I shouldn't have.
I will ignore that.
Let me see if I
can find it here.
All right.
Apparently I did not
include the slides
I thought I included about
the two other game engines.
So I'll talk about
those instead.
So there's another engine
call Haxe Flixel, which
is sort of a port of Flixel
to a language called Haxe.
This is an engine that
we have not used yet.
We've looked over
it a little bit.
And it certainly
looks very promising.
It's using the very
same Flixel style.
It is, however, using
an interesting language
named Haxe, which is mostly
based on ActionScript.
But it has some Java and
C#-like features to it.
It does some crazy
stuff, though.
So it might be a little
bit interesting to use.
Haxe compiles down to a language
of your choice, which it then
compiles.
So for example, if you want
to export your Haxe to Flash,
you'll compile your Haxe to
ActionScript, which will then
get compiled to a Flash app.
Or if you want to
make an iOS app,
you'll probably compile it to
the [? XCode ?] Objective-C,
and then compile that.
But basically, it tries to
be all things to all people.
Which is really
kind of dangerous.
But hopefully, for the kind
of smallish project we're
talking about, that'll be find.
I call that one a noose,
because we haven't used it much.
But it has all the simplicity of
Flixel for the Haxe Flixel game
engine.
So that is a good thing.
The other one we're
looking at using this year
is called Phaser, which we know
not too much about in this lab.
The Education
Arcade is using it.
And they seemed to like it.
And it is an ActionScript,
HTML5 style of engine.
That is not the
most mature platform
to build on, because of
all the browser differences
and stuff like that.
But it is certainly possible.
I recommend if you
end up using Phaser
that rather than coding
in pure JavaScript,
you code in TrueScript,
which is basically a strongly
typed version of JavaScript.
We'll get on to the rest of it.
PHILLIP TAN: TrueScript?
TypeScript?
ANDREW GRANT: Sorry TypeScript.
Yes, TypeScript.
So when you're
learning an engine,
you start with tutorials.
That's the easiest thing to do.
Once you've learned
three or four engines,
you might not use tutorials.
But until then, I would
say you should actually
go through something that
someone's written and thought
about how to progress.
Do something extremely small.
Don't start with the be-all and
end-all game of awesomeness.
Start with something
very, very easy.
And then after you've
done that, you're
going to discover that
you've done some things.
Then read the documentation
a little bit more.
Because you're going to
be better at picking up
stuff after you have
questions in your head.
Even if you don't realize
what questions you've got.
And we're warming
up to an assignment
where we're going to
hand you a game engine
and you're going to take a
look at it over the weekend,
or over the week.
But the thing you
need to remember
is that all software
really does suck.
And game engines
are no exception.
At this point,
invariably, somebody
will claim that
Linux doesn't suck.
To which I'll have to
claim that it does.
But it's also awesome.
And that's the thing about
software and game engines.
You have to really
understand and appreciate
the ins and outs of Linux to
understand the ways in which it
really does suck, but there are
ways in which it's really also
really awesome.
Operating systems all, really,
are pretty bad, I suspect.
Windows and Mac-- you
can make huge arguments
about all of them.
Photoshop we talked
about earlier.
It's an awesomely powerful tool.
But to sit down and actually
start using it as a beginner,
as a newbie, is a
miserable experience.
I think you've probably all
had very similar experiences
with software.
It's buggy.
It's painful.
This is true for
game engines, too.
You're going to try
out a game engine.
And you're going to probably
come back to class thinking,
I tried Unity.
It was terrible.
I didn't understand
what was going on.
It was really hard.
And then you'll hear someone
else talk about Flixel.
And you'll think, wow, I didn't
have any of those problems.
And so this is the trick.
All software sucks.
And your job is to find
the software that sucks
in ways that you can handle.
Right?
You don't mind so
much that you have
to think in 3D for
Unity, because you're
willing to put up
with that because you
get these cool,
nice, rendered look.
Or maybe you have to
deal with the fact
that, yeah, Flixel's
written in ActionScript 3.
And ugh, I hate that language.
But boy, it sure is easy to
put stuff up on the screen,
and have spaceships
moving around shooting
each other in, like, a
day, with no problem.
And these are the kinds
of trade-offs you're
going to have to look at.
So when you're trying
to evaluate a game
engine, or any piece
of software, really,
but game engines for
this class, you're
going to think about the
ways in which it's terrible.
But also think about the
ways in which it's great.
And when you get together and
talk with a team for projects
two through four about
what game engine to use,
you're going to want to be
able to say intelligently,
I don't like Flixel
because of these things.
But actually I can
live with those things.
Or, I don't like Unity
because of this thing,
and I really just
can't get past it.
And if your team's insisting
on using that engine,
and you really know you
really don't like it,
consider another team.
And that's not bad.
Different people are going
to have different preferences
for different styles.
And that's part of what
we're going to be doing.
Any time you're going
to be forming a team
or trying to work
with a team, you're
going to have to
figure out what works
for you, what's hard for
you, what's easy for you.
And match yourself up with
tasks or software that
matches your set of skills.
Or, if you want to
challenge yourself, OK.
Be ready to challenge
yourself and try something
that you thought was
too hard or too painful.
But be aware that
you're doing that.
Because you need to
let your team know,
hey, I'm going to be on
a learning curve here.
You're going to
have to help me out.
So as you look at
a game engine, be
aware that it is going
to disappoint you.
That's just the way it is.
But try to figure out where
the disappointments are.
To that end, one of
our assignments-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Which 2D game engine
would you suggest for those who
are comfortable
with Java and C#?
ANDREW GRANT: With Java and C#?
It kind of depends
on the situation.
I would actually still
suggest, for most simple--
which game engine
should I use for 2D?
And the answer is, if
you have no 3D experience
whatsoever, I would still
recommend Flixel today.
If you are comfortable with 3D
and some of the barriers there,
I would go with Unity.
I personally use Unity
for my own development.
That said, what
we're going to do
is everybody's going to take
a look at a game engine.
So you'll have at
least one of the four
that we're talking
about for the class
that you're familiar with.
And hopefully in the
next couple of weeks,
you'll get your own preference.
Because I can easily say, sure.
Flixel's great for 2D games.
And it is, for the
right kind of 2D games.
It's not good for
all the 2D games.
An isometric thing with
lots of farms and stuff--
you might be able to do it.
But you might be more
comfortable using a 3D approach
or whatever.
So in other words, it really
depends on the game, too.
I wish I could give
you an easy answer.
But I can't, which is
why the whole lecture.
So we have an assignment, which
we'll hand out to you now.
And we're going to talk
about it one week from now.
And do stay tuned.
Because we're not done talking
at you, or giving assignments.
PHILLIP TAN: Do we
hand these out, too?
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, the
game engine tutorial?
Yes.
What I want you to do is pick
a game engine out of this hat.
And pass it on.
If you do not like the game
engine that you get, trade.
Um, sure.
Feel free.
Take a handful.
If I run out, I
have more tokens.
But this is what
I start with, just
to make sure there's
a good distribution.
Just go ahead and
hand this back.
I don't need to be with it.
So one of the things we're
going to do next Wednesday
is try to do a source
control exercise, which
will introduce you
to source control,
and hopefully
refresh some of you.
So ideally, if you
can, we want you
to bring in a development
machine, a laptop
if that's what you're
using, on that Wednesday.
If you only have
a desktop, don't.
If you've got no
computer, don't.
But you know, try to
bring in a development
machine of some kind that you
can actually use on Wednesday.
Ideally, it's the machine
you used to do the tutorials,
so you have your code on it.
Let's see.
What else do we
want to say there?
We don't want you to
spend more than four hours
on this exercise.
There is no "turn in"
for this exercise.
What we want is,
on Wednesday, we're
going to be able to talk
about the game engine
that you looked at.
We want to be able to talk about
its pluses and its minuses,
and what was frustrating.
If it took you all
four hours just
to install the stupid
thing in the first place,
that's information.
We want to know that.
Because that will help
people choose to not use
that game engine, for example.
But basically, we want to be
able to talk intelligently
in the groups, amongst
yourselves, about the game
engine pros and cons.
That's the main goal.
OK.
Any questions or
comments so far?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] can't
just pick just any one
of those [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: So we can only trade.
But once you have
the [? others ?]
you can't [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
Correct.
Do not pick a game
engine at random.
You may trade the one
you've got in your hand
with someone else who has a
different one in their hand.
This is not just-- it's
partially arbitrary.
But mostly it's to make sure
that all the engines are
covered about equally.
Also, there's two
entries for Unity.
One is sort of thinking
about it in 3D,
and one is thinking about it 2D.
And because Unity has recently
added sort of a 2D layer
on top of it that
you can sort of use.
It's a sprite-based engine.
So we want you to put
that through its paces,
too, to compare to the
other 2D engines, to Java.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREW GRANT: So I've
never had much of a problem
transitioning between the two.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
ANDREW GRANT: Let's see.
Yeah, I would
trade if you could.
RIK EBERHARDT: So,
like we said, this
is a video game development or
video game production class.
It's about team management,
project management.
We're spending a lot of time
on those kind of topics.
We aren't spending a ton of time
talking about design in class.
But we were jerks.
And we're giving you a really,
really hard design constraint
to work with for product four.
So we're going to have
some optional assignments,
optional reading--
basically things that we're
going to list on Stellar,
and a couple lectures
we're going to give--
basically just kind of opening
your minds towards design.
So you can think through some
of the big, hairy problems when
it comes to designing
some of these things.
The first thing is talking
about the theme for the course
for the semester.
So we're talking about
meaningful decisions in games.
So we're asking you, when you're
creating these four projects,
to think about what
decisions your players
are making during the
game at all times,
and to make sure that all
those decisions they make
are meaningful.
And this is going to be
the foundation for the four
projects that you're working on.
All the constraints are going to
be based on this kind of thing.
So first off, what do we
mean by meaningful decisions?
This is what I
mean when I say it.
There's other
definitions out there.
But this is the bare minimum.
It should do this.
It should have this.
So three things-- any decision
a player makes in a game
has an effect on the
game's overall state.
So I make a decision.
Something changed.
Not only did something
change, but that change
ripples through the
systems within the game.
It affects the
entire game state,
the entire game world-- not
just what the player might have,
not just the
player's performance,
not just the player's abilities.
So a jump in these
games-- it can
be meaningful in some games.
But for this particular game
and this particular use,
if the jump affects everything
else in the game in some form,
that was really meaningful.
And I'd be surprised
to see a jump do that.
But it probably isn't.
It's probably just a way
to get over an obstacle.
So there's something else.
There's some other kind of
decision a player has to make,
rather than just that
one small decision.
Third-- there should be
sufficient feedback--
and we'll talk about feedback
later on and what exactly
we mean by that-- that lets
the player be aware that they
made that decision.
Not only did I make
a decision, but I
knew that I made a decision.
There was something
that happened
in the game that prompted
me to make that decision.
And I actively
made the decision.
I made the choice to
make the decision.
I know I made the decision.
And I actually see all those
effects happen in some form.
At the bare minimum,
I make a decision.
I see some short-term effects.
There might be long-term effects
that I don't see right now,
but I will have the
opportunity to see later.
That's a little
bit more advanced.
So basically this
lecture is really
just going to be talking
about some example games
that, when we're talking about
the games we would like you
to make in class, these are kind
of the exemplar games for this.
These are the games
that we think of when
we think of this kind of thing.
And the problem that I
think is going to come up
is we're going to sometimes
call them strategy games, which
is a really loaded term.
What is a strategy game?
Does anybody have a definition
for what a strategy game is?
Somebody who took-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RIK EBERHARDT:
Yeah, a game that's
going to require
a lot of thinking.
A game that's going to require--
and by thinking, there's
a lot of actions
that happen when
we talk about player thinking.
Like all right, so I'm thinking.
So if I'm thinking, I
might not be taking action.
So I might be thinking
to take an action.
I might be planning.
That's going to be part of it.
I might be thinking.
But there's something that's
distracting me for thinking.
Maybe I have to make
actions really, really fast.
Or I can make actions and I can
think a long period of time.
All that is the
big wide spectrum
of what we're talking
about with strategy games.
Can anybody list some
strategy games they've played
or have heard about?
AUDIENCE: Age of Empires.
RIK EBERHARDT: Age of
Empires-- which one?
AUDIENCE: The second one.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yes it is.
[LAUGHTER]
Civilization.
Yes.
Which one?
AUDIENCE: V.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
I like that one, too.
[LAUGHTER]
More.
What's that?
No?
AUDIENCE: StarCraft.
RIK EBERHARDT: StarCraft.
Which one?
AUDIENCE: I've only played II.
RIK EBERHARDT: I played I.
But I haven't played II.
But he plays II.
A lot.
More.
AUDIENCE: Fire Emblem.
RIK EBERHARDT: Fire Emblem--
ooh, that's a really good one.
Which one?
All of them, yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Go.
RIK EBERHARDT: Go.
Ooh.
You took the board game class.
AUDIENCE: I play MOBAs.
RIK EBERHARDT:
MOBAs-- so which ones?
What's a MOBA, really?
AUDIENCE: Like, [? Noldor ?]
or League of Legends.
RIK EBERHARDT: So what
does MOBA stand for,
for people who don't play it?
AUDIENCE: Massive
Online Battle Arena.
RIK EBERHARDT: Massive
And you were talking
about League of Legends.
How many people
here-- raise your hand
if you played League of Legends.
OK.
Riot's coming September 24 to
talk about to us about that.
How many people have played
DotA, Defense of the Ancients?
The same people,
for the most part.
Cool.
So that's a really good spread.
And actually, that's
exactly what I expected--
except for the Go
person-- to hear,
are games about war, and
games about conflict,
and games about fighting
against another player,
or against a
computer-controlled opponent.
That's not exactly
what we mean when
we talk about strategy
games for the broader
aspect of the class.
But it's a great place to start.
And that's where
we're going to start.
So here's Civilization V,
and here's StarCraft II.
I'm going to use these
for a couple examples.
And then we're
going to split off.
And each of us are
going to talk about some
of our favorite games that
we think of when we say,
this was a really cool mechanic.
This is a really cool thing
I've seen in a strategy
game, or an aspect of strategy
or an aspect of tactics
that I've seen,
and I'd love to see
happen in some of the game we
make over the next semester.
So there's two types of
decision-making that I see.
And again, this is all just
me in my head a couple days
ago putting a lecture together.
It's not an academic taxonomy.
It's to help us out
when we're thinking
about the kinds of decisions
we're making in these games.
There's two kinds of decisions
that happen in these games.
There's a micro-level
decision-- short-term decisions
I make that help
me out right now.
There's macro decisions
or long-term decisions.
And I'm using micro
and macro because I'm
obsessed with economics, even
though I don't understand it.
But also because
you see the games
represented that way sometimes.
There's the micro,
where I'm looking really
tight at this one
aspect of the game,
and the macro, where
I can see a bigger,
expanded version of the world.
I can see the systems
and the gears that
are happening behind the world.
And they're represented
in many ways.
And I'll talk about a
couple examples there.
ANDREW GRANT: People
often use "tactics"
to describe micro, and
"strategy" to describe macro.
So there's actually a difference
between strategy and tactics.
That's one way of
thinking about it.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
So for the micro--
exactly, tactical.
The way this is
often represented
in these kind of war
games or strategy games--
there's usually some kind of
spatial component going on.
There's some kind of
placement going on.
There might be some
direct conflict happening.
So I've got an army.
And it's facing
off another army.
And we're throwing spears
or shooting each other
with lasers-- basically
the same thing.
But there's also firefighting.
There's another kind of
conflict that happens.
And by firefighting,
I don't mean fires.
But I've got a problem
that just happened.
And I need to solve it.
I need to react to it.
So it's reactive.
I might have this really
long long-term strategy.
But unfortunately I've
got to make some decisions
right now that may or may not
hurt my long-term strategy.
There are some tactical
decisions I need to make.
It's not always
reactive, though.
Sometimes what
we're talking about
is you're executing a plan.
I've set up a
long-term strategy.
And now here's the
final dramatic moment
where I get to actually
implement the thing
and see if it works--
throw the dudes on the map,
and they're going to die or not.
And when we're talking
about tactical,
there's always a
short-term resolution.
So I do a thing-- feedback.
I know it happened.
There could be
long-term ramifications.
But there's definitely
a short-term resolution
to the decision I just
made at that point.
So my example, because
I am a huge Civilization
nerd-- Civilization V brought
some very tactical game
play to the series
that wasn't really
there in previous installments.
So in the past, you could
stack units on a tile.
So Civilization is
basically a game
made of tiles where you're
placing items on tiles.
And the tiles give you
bonuses or whatnot.
That's the very, very
basic version of it.
In this case, what we have--
and it's kind of blurry--
but you have a city
in the center, where
that arrow is pointing to.
You have these blue units
surrounding the city,
and a couple small
yellow units going on.
Can anybody describe what's
going on in this scene?
AUDIENCE: A raid.
RIK EBERHARDT: What's that?
RIK EBERHARDT: A raid.
So we're fighting.
What kind of
decisions is a player
being asked to do right now?
And the player is
the blue player
that has the red arrow there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RIK EBERHARDT: What's that?
RIK EBERHARDT: So yeah.
You're trying to
implement the strategy.
Can you kind of see--
apologies if you can't make out
the quality of the slide.
Can you see what is
exactly going on?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're about to make
a ranged attack with the cannon
against the city.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
So first thing is,
all right, so I've
got a range attack that
is really diagonally away
from the city.
It's two hexes away.
I can do a range attack on it.
The cool thing about
this is that the city
can't attack me right now.
Well, actually it can.
But I'm making a mistake there.
But it's not the knight's turn.
So the knight can't attack
the ranged attack right now.
The other thing that's
happening is the player
had a long-term strategy,
which meant that they brought
some foot soldiers in
to surround the city,
protecting the ranged attacker.
They've also got this thing
called Zone of Control
going on in this.
All right, here's
an enemy person.
Here's an enemy person.
If any of these
people try to attack
any of these blue
people, there's
some kind of negative
modifier going on.
Because the blue player
has set it up such that
they're being flanked.
So there's some
spatial placement
going on that's been decided.
Not only did they have to
get all the units over here,
but once they were
here, they had
to put those units
in the right places
for this tactical
maneuver to happen.
So really, in
Civilization V, we're
talking about tactical
in one aspect of it.
In the combat
aspect of it, we're
talking about flanking, army
positioning, Zone of Control,
preventing other players
from entering into tiles,
controlling areas, and making
this area basically more
effective for the
blue player to attack
the city than for the
yellow player to defend it.
So how did the player get there?
How did blue get
into that situation?
They had an operational
or strategic plan
that they set forth.
They were able to develop
those weapons that they had.
They were able to make
them in the right location.
And then they were able
to transport them over
to the right location.
So if we're talking
about military strategy,
tactics, that might be
closer to logistics,
supply chain, getting
supply into the area.
The strategy that might
actually be happening
is even bigger than that.
So this is where it
gets into the realm
that I really nerd
out in is spreadsheets
of numbers and modifiers.
There's resources
you need to manage.
I need to anticipate what's
going to be there and have
the right things
built in time for them
to be useful in that situation.
There's an economic system
I need to manipulate and do
well with in order to afford the
units that I want over there.
If I'm playing well, I need to
be proactive in my strategy.
All strategy really
should be proactive.
And someone can argue with
me if there is such a thing
as reactive strategy.
But really, it could
be proactive and wrong.
But you did it beforehand.
You set up the gears
in motion for it
to play out the way it did.
And you're always planning
for some long-term future.
So in Civilization V, one way
that this plays out non-combat
is city placement.
Where I put my city is
incredibly important.
Using the real world map of
Africa, what they've done
is the designers put
these resources--
those circular items-- spices,
bananas, silk, diamonds, oil.
Some of the resources
are luxury resources.
So they help my cities be happy.
They help my citizens work
well and be productive.
There's agricultural
resources that help
my cities grow and be healthy.
And then there's
strategic resources--
and I could be mixing
these terms up.
They're things that are going
to help me build things.
So oil or steel or iron will
help me build better units.
So my strategy here--
there's a little bit
of tactics going on,
where when I actually
get my settler in
the right place,
I need to then find a
very specific place to go.
But long-term, if I'm
thinking about the long term,
I want to place
my cities in a way
where they're near resources.
They're near my friendly cities.
They have room to grow.
Because if I group my cities
too close to each other,
they're not going
to be as efficient.
This is really
apparent if anybody's
played Civilization
II, where there's
one real strategy to the game.
And that's just build a
city every three hexes.
That's just how it works.
And in the later games, they
tried to introduce some nuance
to that.
And again, I'm mixing
strategy and tactics
as we're talking about this.
They all go hand in hand.
A lot of the games
that we've played,
and that are these strategy
games that you talked about,
are actually more
tactical games.
There's much more emphasis
placed on the short-term thing
I do now than the long term.
That's not to say there isn't
long term in these games.
If anybody's played
League of Legends,
the metagame about the pick
process, so what champ to pick
or not.
That's a strategic maneuver.
You're planning for
a long-term strategy
that you're going to
play out within the game.
And not only are
you planning for it.
You picked it, and then
you're stuck with it.
So those decisions last.
With StarCraft II
it's build order,
which can be a little
bit more flexible.
There are build
orders that you can--
that's build order
in that you are
building units and buildings
and upgrades in the right order,
such that you're prepared for
multiple different strategies
coming into them.
And I could be butchering that.
I'm not a
PHILLIP TAN: That's
definitely a good [INAUDIBLE]
RIK EBERHARDT: Cool.
But that's more flexible.
Because I actually have
time within the game
to make some tactical changes
to that long-term strategy
that I decided on early.
Unless you're playing
professionally.
And then I've just
seem that they just
GG after five minutes.
So anybody recognize this quote?
Sid Meier, the developer
for Civilization,
famously said, "a good game is a
series of interesting choices."
It's very much the
case for the games
that we're making in this class.
The thing I want to note is
strive for interesting choices
in your games.
Be prepared for your choices
not to be interesting.
Try to iterate through them
and make them more interesting.
But we don't have a ton
of time to really help
you make the greatest
games in the world.
Right?
So we want your choices
to be meaningful.
And if one or two of them
are interesting, awesome.
You did a really,
really good job
with the game development
process of it.
I'm going to do a really,
really quick talk about how you
can make things interesting.
And we're going to come back
to it in later projects.
But I just want to kind of
get these two terms out there.
We're going to talk about
conflict and tension.
So what is conflict?
If I say the words
conflict and tension,
what's the definitions
you're more familiar with?
Anybody heard it in
drama or writing?
Like the narrative arc--
there's a conflict.
There are two people
who want the same thing.
Or there's an internal conflict.
And that's really what
I'm thinking of when I'm
saying conflict in this case.
It's, what is the conflict
in the player as they're
making these decisions?
What are the trade-offs
they're making?
Do I send an army this way?
Or do I send an army that way?
Or do I not fight at all?
If that is a really hard
decision for the player
to make-- if they can't
calculate it beforehand,
if they have enough information
to know that one may be better
than the other, but
they're not quite sure--
that's what we're talking
about with conflict.
With what Pablo was
playing with us,
the conflict in the
individual teams of,
we know the probabilities.
We can calculate that.
But are we sure?
Are we sure it's going
to play out that way?
I really wish he
had used to cones.
Because I really want
to know how often
the cone's going
to fall on its end.
And then tension are ways
we can modify that conflict.
Maybe there's no
conflict existing.
And we need to use tension
to create some conflict.
Maybe there's a little
bit of conflict going on,
and tension's going to amplify
that and make it more dramatic.
And there's just some basic
things you can change.
And when we talk about
the example games,
and if you play these example
games over the weekend,
think about these terms.
If I were to change
the timing in a game,
or the speed with which
you can make decisions,
or the precision that's required
to make those decisions--
would that increase
the conflict?
And by increasing
the conflict there,
are the choices
more interesting?
Is the game more engaging,
or the game more fun?
Limitations are
awesome in games.
Limitations are really how you
can design and control where
and what a player can do.
So how many options do
you give the player?
Do you give them two, or
three, or five, or infinite?
I can tell you right now.
Having infinite choices is
really, really difficult,
but not that interesting.
Space, costs, economics,
information, fog of war--
we've seen in some of
these strategy games
where you can only
see things that are
around where your units.
And you can't see
things outside of that.
These are all methods we use as
designers to create conflict,
to make those choices that
we're asking our players
to make interesting.
So example games-- what
I'd love for you to do--
and this is totally optional.
But if you're interested in
design, I totally recommend it.
Over the weekend,
play some games.
We're going to talk
about these games.
And think about these things.
And the slides are on Stellar.
Think about the
types of decisions
you can make, the
timing of the decisions,
whether the game is
single-player or multiplayer,
if there's competitive
or co-op play, if there's
teams or alliances, and what
kind of conflict and tension
exists in the game.
All of these are
things that we're
going to be asking you as
designers over the semester
to decide on, to design,
to craft, to create
a very particular experience
that you're trying to create.
So Drew's going to kick
us off with this game.
ANDREW GRANT: Who's
played backgammon?
Wow, really?
No one plays backgammon anymore.
All right.
Backgammon is a
pretty classic game.
It was invented a good,
oh, 5,000 years ago or so,
about the time that we
learned how to write.
It's got a lot of
planning, oddly enough.
There's a lot of probability
and randomness to it.
But you can plan
for that randomness
by setting your pieces
in the right spots.
You can choose
different strategies.
Are you going to be aggressive
to take the other person's
pieces?
Or are you going to
be defensive, and just
try to protect yourself?
Are you going to leave something
in the opponent's backfield,
so if you're losing
at the end, you
can maybe mess them up somehow?
Or when do you change from
trying to mess them up
to shooting for the end goal?
There's a couple different
ways to play backgammon, oddly
enough.
And it actually is
a fairly deep game.
There's a lot of
probability involved,
but some tactics
and some strategy
going on in there, too.
If you haven't played it
and you like board games,
it's well worth playing.
Because I think a
lot of the things
that you're going to see
in modern board games
really owe a lot to this game
right here, especially when you
add randomness as a mechanic.
Go and chess are
obviously really,
really awesome games, too.
But they're a very
different style of game.
Because they don't have
the randomness in there.
It's a very, very different
way of thinking about it.
This is another one where I
think there's more planning
than people give it credit for.
Who's played Twister?
That's more like it.
OK.
So in Twister you
actually can plan ahead.
You probably don't.
But if you played Twister
a lot, you might start.
You might realize, if I
put my right foot there
I'm really screwed if
they call red next time.
So I guess I won't.
I'll put it over there.
It kind of depends on how
many people are playing.
If there's enough people
playing, you can't do that.
You just have to be fast.
So Twister is an
interesting game
where sometimes you have to
make your decision extremely
quickly.
Is there strategy in Twister?
Anyone?
I see some nods.
What decisions would you make?
AUDIENCE: Maybe to
go under somebody,
if you have to reach and
lift them off the board.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Yes.
So there's a strategy to
Twister if you want to play
Twister to win, darn it.
And maybe you're thinking
that I've got better balance.
Or maybe I'm a little
bit bigger than they are.
I bet I can nudge
them a little bit.
That would work.
Right?
That does work.
Or maybe you want to play off
in your own little corner?
That works, too, unless no
one else lets you do it.
Or if you get yourself
too tangled up,
you can't move even
when you're by yourself.
Have you done that or seen that?
Someone's off by
themselves doing Twister
and they fall over
with no one near them?
It totally happens.
There's other strategic
decisions for Twister.
Are you trying to win?
Are you trying to stay near
someone, or away from someone?
There are totally other
game goals to Twister.
And they're up to the
people who are playing it.
What is next?
RIK EBERHARDT: Sara.
SARA VERRILLI: OK.
That would be me.
So this is not what
everybody thinks of when
they think of strategic games.
But I want to point
out that decisions come
in a lot of different styles.
You're not going to ever ruin
your game by any decisions
you make in FarmVille,
particularly.
But it is a game
that makes people
make a lot of choices
about what they
want to do, relatively freely.
The strategy-- where strategy
and resource management
comes into FarmVille is
you have a limited number
of actions you can take.
Which means you can only
play the game for so long.
Assuming you do not want to
become one of those people who
spends a big pile of money
playing FarmVille, which
I'm going to assume you are.
So you need to
manage your actions,
and think about how many
actions you're taking,
and think about when you want
to come back to the game.
And the way they do
that, and the way
that you can game
that system, is
by looking at how long
it takes things to grow,
what you want to grow,
what you want to make.
FarmVille is actually at
this point kind of outdated,
because they've
moved to FarmVille 2.
But I did not actually
want to go there and play
it to have the expertise
to tell you about it.
I did spend enough
time playing FarmVille
to know that there's
actually a whole lot
of interesting decisions
you get to make there.
And it's not a game
people think of when they
think of meaningful decisions.
Because they've
heard a whole lot of,
oh my god, it's that click game.
Just because it's
a game that doesn't
have a lot of deep
consequences doesn't
mean it can't have
a lot of deep play.
Am I hitting the right button?
Let's find out.
So Plants vs. Zombies is
essentially a really popular
tower defense game.
And tower defense
was not very popular
until Plants vs.
Zombies came out.
Because most people
hadn't done it very well
or presented it very well.
But in Plants vs. Zombies,
you've got tons of choices.
Who here has played
Plants vs. Zombies?
Let me ask the first question.
OK.
So yeah, you know what
I'm talking about.
They got the UI
right, absolutely.
So it's easy to play.
And every time you go in to
play a level, you get to choose.
Which strategy are
you going to use?
You've got sort of
the long-term strategy
choice for each
level, where you get
to choose which
creatures you're taking
or which plants you're taking.
And you can go back
and play each level
with a completely
different set of plants,
and still succeed,
or fail at it.
In my case, it's
often more failing.
They give you just
enough information
so you can think about
what you're going to bring.
You can see what's coming in.
You don't know how many of
those are going to come.
You don't know when
they're going to come.
So you have to both
plan for, I know there's
going to be a zombie need.
But I don't know how
much of them it is.
How much resources
do I need to devote
to worrying about the
zom-- zom-- zombies.
I'm not getting that
right at all, am I?
How much resources do I
have to worry about devoting
to that versus all the other
threats I've got coming in?
Now I have to admit
something terrible.
My daughters play this game.
And I have watched
them play this game.
But I haven't actually
played this game.
And I was going to play it last
night so I could talk about it.
And then my daughters
hid my iPad on me.
It's very hard to
download a game
when you don't have the
device to download it onto.
So has anybody else
played this game?
OK.
A few people have.
Your goal in this game
is you're a virus.
You would like to evolve
and hopefully take out
all of humanity.
And as you're playing the
game as the player guiding
the virus's development, you
get to make a lot of choices.
How lethal is it?
What kind of
symptoms do you have?
How easy is it to spread?
My daughters are
working on the infect
the whole planet with a
completely symptomless disease
tactic, and then evolve
quickly up to lethality
and take everybody out.
They haven't succeeded at this.
It sounds like the
perfect strategy.
But they haven't
succeeded at this.
Because you kind of need
symptoms to cause damage.
And they can't evolve
the symptoms fast enough.
Once they've gotten
everyone infected
and they're going from
completely harmless to deadly,
they can't manage to
evolve it fast enough.
So it's got a lot
of interesting play
there, where you've got a
lot of different tactics.
I think they can get it
someday, but they haven't yet.
They'll need to try
a different tactic.
And finally, a game I have
played an awful lot of
is Pandemic.
Who here has played Pandemic?
OK.
So what is the main
tactic and resource
you have in this game,
if you've played it?
AUDIENCE: Turns.
SARA VERRILLI:
Turns-- well, time.
Time.
Yeah.
In a lot of ways, in this game,
what you're playing against
is time.
Because when you
run out of the deck,
if you haven't managed to
clear things, the game is over.
And the resource you've got,
and the choices you've got,
is where people are going and
which area they're fighting.
The overall plan of
the game, of course,
is there are four
epidemics raging.
You're the CDC.
You need to find cures
for all the plagues
before they take out
the rest of humanity.
And so you have to balance
both your long-term strategy
of finding a cure
for each of diseases
with the short-term
strategy of keeping
the diseases under
control, so that you
don't end up with
everything being destroyed.
PHILLIP TAN: All right, my turn.
[INAUDIBLE] Who's
played Dominion?
OK, pretty popular.
I certainly recommend it
as a good introduction
to the basic idea of
deck-building games.
Actually, how many people
have played Magic, Yu-Gi-Oh!,
Pokemon card game?
OK.
All right, a lot of that.
In many of those games, and
in Dominion, a lot of the fun
is just building
your own machine,
your own little
engine, that is going
to execute out your strategy.
Now your engine happens
to be a deck of cards.
You get shuffled up, so it's
in some sort of random order.
But you get to choose
what cards go in there.
In a collectible card game
like Magic: the Gathering,
you are buying those cards,
and then assembling the cards,
or there's a draft
[? mechanic ?].
In a game like
Dominion, there is
a way where you buy more cards
while you're playing the game.
But in the end, what
it all comes down to is
as you play this game, you get
cards that go into your deck.
They are going to end up
being shuffled in your deck.
And at some random
time in the future,
it's going to get played out.
And so the cards that you
choose to put into your deck
turns out to be your main
means of motivating you
towards a [INAUDIBLE] strategy.
There are a range of different
ways to play this game,
and different possible
success criteria.
And the really interesting
thing about the Dominion deck
is I think it gets something
like over 20 different kinds
of cards in a box of Dominion.
But you only play with 10 of
them-- 10 plus victory points.
So every time you play
the game, the strategy
starts by just seeing,
what are the 10
cards I've got in front of
me for this session of play?
And then you choose, out
of these 10 cards, what
are the cards that I'm going to
select and in what proportion,
in order to build this
engine that is going
to motivate me towards victory?
So it's an interesting game.
I would strongly
recommend it, if you
know someone who's got
a copy of this game
or any of the expansions.
They're all interchangeable.
Drop7-- mostly played on mobile,
although I think there is also
a browser version of this game.
How many of you
have played this?
Yeah.
Perfect for a T ride, I find.
You can finish a session
in a single trip on the T.
The idea is that you're
just dropping one number
from the top of the screen.
And that number ranges
anywhere between one to seven.
And if you manage to
make a row of numbers
that add up to-- let's
say I have a row of sixes.
And I have six sixes in a row.
Then all of the sixes
are going to disappear.
And it's going to
also clear out some
of those gray circles where
you don't know the numbers yet.
It's going to review the
numbers behind these gray tiles.
You can think of them as tiles
that were turned upside down.
So what you really, really
want to make is chains.
Chains are where, if I have a
six, five, four, three, two,
one, then what happens is
that six is going to burst.
Then that five is
going to burst.
Then that four is
Then a three, and
so on and so forth.
You set up these massive chains.
And basically,
you're just assigning
how you're going to place this.
And if you played a
game like Puyo Puyo--
I'm trying to think-- certain
kinds of Match 3 games
like Bejeweled, you'll get this
sort of chain reaction feeling.
And some games more
than others encourage
you to set up these chains
before you drop the triggering
piece.
Drop7 is very much about that.
So I believe, if you can
find it on a browser,
it should be free.
I'm not so sure whether
the iOS versions are free.
They are?
Great.
I keep forgetting the
computer is on this side.
The StarCraft II visual novel.
AUDIENCE: Wait, is it done?
PHILLIP TAN: No, no.
It's still in development.
Full disclosure, I am
a Kickstarter backer
of this game.
As has been mentioned
many, many times,
I am a StarCraft II player.
But I am not encouraging
you to go and learn
that over the weekend.
Because StarCraft II is more
of a lifestyle kind of thing.
[LAUGHTER]
But if you're just
kind of wanting
to see what the
strategy is about,
this is an interesting
game where--
if you've ever played
a visual novel,
they're kind of like Choose Your
Own Adventure in digital form.
And they are usually
very strong narrative-
and character-driven games.
You play a teenager who has
moved to Korea in the hopes
to start his or her
pro gaming career.
And you go into a LAN center.
And you play random
games against people.
Only these are the kinds of
decisions you get to make.
Which strategy are
you going to go for?
I usually find this to be
a really, really good way
of conveying the macro-level
decisions, the really, really
high-level long-term
strategic decisions
that you're going to make.
Because you're not
actually playing StarCraft.
You are choosing between
two or three choices.
And then it plays out.
But it gives you a good idea of
the kind of high-level decision
making.
Whereas most people see
someone play StarCraft as like,
the [KEY-CLACKING NOISE].
And you're not seeing
that long term strategy.
So we do have a Let's Play up.
And the URL is there.
But if you just Google MIT Game
Lab, StarCraft II visual novel,
you'll see the YouTube video
and get an idea of that.
Because I'm not so sure if you
can still download the demo.
But the demo does have
some of these features.
ANDREW GRANT: I am last..
Mini Metro.
All right.
So my games that I
chose-- what's up?
Oh, thank you.
Cool.
So this one I really
like as an example.
Eww, it looks awful
on the screen, though.
So I really like this
one as an example
because it has not
yet been published.
On their website they
have their alpha build.
And if you were to buy their
game, what you would see
is the beta build.
And then later on, when it
actually does publish-- you
guys can even see
this on YouTube.
You can see what it's going
to look like when you actually
buy the final game.
It plays exactly the same.
It looks polished.
It's a really good
example of here's
a game that works and
is functionally perfect.
And they could have
just shipped it.
And I'm really glad that
did, because I play it a lot.
And when they
finally ship it, it's
still going to play
the exact same way.
It's just going to be
a little bit prettier.
And it really doesn't matter.
I don't really care about that.
That's something that we're
going to stress in this game.
We're more concerned about
that, is it playable?
Does it work?
Can I understand how to play
it-- more so than the pretty,
more so than the aesthetic
and visual polish.
So in this game, it is a
game about managing a subway.
All of the sudden
a subway station
appears in the middle of space.
And you have to
build a line to it.
So you build your line.
And then passengers randomly
appear on the subway trains.
But you don't have to actually
get them from place to place.
You don't control the trains.
You just build the lines.
The trains move on their own.
And they're moving
at a constant rate.
So you can kind of
guess when the train
is going to get to the station.
There are strategies
to-- you can move
your lines around a little bit.
But once your lines are in
place, for the most part,
they're static.
You can't really change
them all that much.
So there's some
limitations going on
between how much you
can move a line or not.
At the end, if you
last a week, it's
going to give you
one of three options
to do a power-up, basically.
Either you can build a
new line, add a new train,
increase the
capacity of a train.
So you're making a
permanent choice there.
And that's going to
affect the later game.
So you're making all
sorts of these decisions
at both a macro and micro level.
And there's a really good
write-up about the game
right there, if you
just want to read that.
FTL-- I lost a ton
of productivity
a few months ago
because of this game.
It is a game about
fighting in spaceships
without actually controlling
all the fighting so much.
You're actually upgrading your
ship, increasing your capacity,
buying crew members-- and
hoping your crew members survive
is a lot of it.
You could-- and I
do this-- manually
control all your weapons.
And actually to succeed,
you really do have to.
Because the interesting
thing with this game is it's
a perma-death game.
As soon as you die, it's dead.
You have to start over.
You have to restart the game.
Luckily the game only takes
about three hours to play.
But you're lucky if you get
through those three hours.
And when you finally
get to the last boss,
and you're there-- the thing
about this game is in order
to get to that boss, there's all
sorts of different challenges
you're facing.
And you're making
these decisions about,
do I buy this weapon
or that weapon
to help me with the thing
I know that I'm going
to face in the next sector?
Because I'm losing health.
I'm really dying here.
But is this weapon
really going to help me
when I get to the boss?
You're constantly
going back and forth.
So I'll often find, after three
or four, that I'm at the boss
and I'm completely ill-equipped
to fight this thing.
And I just die.
But I do play out to the
end, because it's fun.
Last game I have--
this one's free online.
It's called Gridland.
If anybody's played the game, A
Dark Room, a text-based supply
chain game, this is
the Match 3 version
of that game, a little bit.
There's two stages in
the game-- day and night.
It's Match 3, so you
just collect three gems.
And you get whatever the
gems represent-- resources
like clay, wood, and
stone, food, paper, gems.
You can upgrade your little
factories to make better gems.
Every time you
upgrade one of these,
though-- so if you
upgrade your wood,
you'll get a better sword.
If you upgrade your
clay, which you
need to make the
better wood, you're
going to get in the
nighttime a stronger monster.
So in this case, this
is immediately daytime
and then shifted over to night.
The exact same layout is there.
It's just the logs
have become shields.
The little blue things that
are supposed to be iron
become swords.
And all the other
things become enemies.
So a lot of the
strategy for this game
is, what's going to help me now?
What's going to help
me in the future?
What's going to hurt
And what's going to
hurt me immediately
as I switch over to night?
Once I get into the
night mode, I'll
have known exactly what
I'm going to be facing.
Because I set that stage up.
So unlike Bejeweled where you're
just constantly just clicking
things, or Candy Crush
where you're just
constantly just
clicking things, there's
actually no time limit on this.
And it took me--
it's embarrassing
how long it took me-- a day
or two to realize that I
didn't have to play that way.
I could just wait,
pause, and play.
There wasn't going to
be a time limit pushing
me to continue moving forward.
And that's an interesting
presentation thing.
When you're
presenting your games,
especially if you're
using a previous genre,
there's going to be genre
conventions that the players
are going to understand.
That is going to shape
their user experience.
And we'll be talking about
that about project three.
So that's it.
If you want to play these
games or watch these games
on YouTube, please do.
And if you want to know more
about choice and conflict,
there's a nine-minute
video at Extra Credits.
We use Extra Credits a
lot, because they're short.
They're fun videos
on game design.
I highly recommend
it for this class
to give you a leg up on some
of the design challenges
that we're facing here.